[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
you
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
um
so
this
[Laughter]
so
[Laughter]
one
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
my
so
[Laughter]
one
so
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
one
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
there's no time
the time is 13. o'clock
hey everybody
happy birthday to me and we are here
we are here and we got the cake yeah we
got cake right there right there and
look it's dennis is here
h.h holmes is here
i was gonna make them i was trying to
make the little party hats earlier but i
[ __ ] them up
so i didn't want it then i thought oh
duh i could have just like cut out
little triangles and then like taped
them to the fronts of their heads
so it would look like that from the
front but oh well let me try to get the
cake
in there look at this look at this cake
please don't drop it what kind of cake
is this
it's a it's a cannoli cake like some
kind of it has like it's vanilla
rum yeah and it has like cannoli cream
in it or something i got it from the
publix bakery and i was like scrolling
through all their offerings and i was
kind of like yeah
that sounds pretty good i was like jenny
let me get you a cake you pick it out
because see i'm not stupid all right
because i'd pick out some [ __ ] jelly
bean cake or
something that was you know oh look at
that thank you very much thank you very
much thank you thank you so much i'll
tell you what why don't you
we go ahead and do the do the uh the
holidays
or the night the holiday celebration it
is a holiday it's a national yeah
happy birthday to you
[Applause]
happy birthday to you thank you there
you go
thank you very much i'll cut the cake
once you get that done yeah i'm just
gonna you know it's like we're trying to
like just take a bite every night yeah
we're not eating we're not gonna eat all
right so we're not just oh you know what
the microphone's way over here yeah you
guys can't
yeah that's probably why right here is
better so it didn't sound good
yeah okay well no i just realized that
it was way over there
that's okay that's okay all right but
yeah and as
because it was because it's my birthday
i have like a whole bunch of
shout outs and stuff like that all kinds
of stuff people have been sending me
and also i did my uh strange realities
the conference thing last night
oh you're making me very nervous it's
okay you could do the show
don't worry about it what is he doing
over there don't worry about it
i did my uh presentation last night at
10 40 uh eastern standard time and that
went pretty well i was like
very very tired and very very nervous
but yeah it seemed to go well and i got
a couple tips in my tip jar
there you go and uh thank you very much
i said you wanted a little piece of
there
yeah i just want a little piece because
i don't want like i said i don't want
anybody having to like listen to me
and stuff now this is from publix i've
never actually had this
flavor sophie doesn't eat cake i
absolutely eat cake
that's not cake that's not good it is
they they're speaking i guarantee that
there's
it's good yeah you need to have vegan
stuff that's not even food no
my mom and other people my family have
made cakes that can dance
yeah okay that's delightful oh yeah it
was good
i had a feeling real good i'm going to
have to eat one of the little half
cannoli that's on the top
mm-hmm but yeah so this is almost as
good as a little debbie
almost yeah almost as good as you're
saying white trash
i'm positive that's got all kind of
buttercream no
then i'll be peaced out again much
earlier
dennis has birthday problems all right
so uh
let me do some shout outs real quick
before i get too much into eating the
cake because i want
because look tom's almost done with his
and then he'll be able to talk while i'm
not sure
that's why i got you that i gotta do you
do
uh-huh don't we all mm-hmm um but yeah
oh lady vazubia says i look about 28 wow
that would be twins because that's the
day
yeah they had some girls put another 20
years on that and you got it
some girl a couple weeks back on the on
the main show comment her name is
jillian i think
i don't know if it's the same julian his
father with julian alexis said she was
short like a garden gnome with big oh i
had some big old legs yeah just yes what
she said
you're gonna have to break it off you
need to set up some pictures
if you're gonna lay it out there you've
gotta prove it
tom's in the garden you better look like
please tell me there has to be a sexy
ass garden gnome halloween costume
there's a sexy everything i'm pretty
sure there is
i wonder it's like because i feel like
they have to come up with new halloween
costumes like every year
are you gonna put oh my god look at the
mess that you made there's like little
there's like little slivered almonds
like all over the [ __ ]
oh this cake is really good though um
but yeah what was i even saying oh um
probably every halloween they have to
come up with x amount of new costumes
so it's like now we're getting down to
the thing where it's like
i don't know a tootsie roll tube um it's
a
marker i don't know it's like so now
they're like just looking around the
office like looking for [ __ ] can we make
a sexy costume out of this
i have seen sexy crayon um
and actually when we were at eye bar for
their halloween party one year
three girls came in dressed up like
sexy bath loofahs like of different
colors
i'm like well that's creative uh
not in person but online a sexy bob ross
like the painter oh i like that
that's sexy okay that's what i mean
they're really really like
scraping the bottom of the barrel and
because i've been thinking about
halloween costumes a lot not only
because halloween is coming up but also
because
i'm designing a board game that has to
that is halloween based
and a lot of it has to do with like
costumes so i'm like thinking of
you know i'm trying to think of costumes
but not stupid ones i really i don't
like those
i you know i like halloween i like scary
costumes i like
ugly costumes even when i was a little
kid you all right
hey jane what somebody's here to see me
yeah
oh my god oh my god
where where the hell did you get that
uh sophie got it that was all me girl
it's
well that's all i need in life you can
just leave that right here
yeah in my office i'm right here
me and beijing have
spock is here he's here
that's so cool you can't get him in the
camera i feel yeah
he's too tall well or you can like yeah
but he seems much bigger to me he's
really tall does anybody know that song
or am i just like talking out my ass
that's like that's they might be giants
you guys
choose actual size yeah sorry i don't
want to like
if you look get like um what there's
maybe two inches that i could probably
cut off no don't cut anything off we're
probably like
children of balance you don't want to do
that the new co-host
you can like tilt it there you go you
can tilt it up nobody needs to
does anybody notice that i wore my
birthday party shirt just like because i
wanted to be
as dorky as possible you're gonna have
to put something underneath the way
i have a million books why don't you
just get a book and put a book in get a
book
look there's a whole shelf full of them
whole
shelves full of books that you can use
what was the 80s song that had spock in
it saying pure energy that was
uh information society what the hell was
the name of that song
uh pure energy i think no no that wasn't
it might have been called that i feel
like it was maybe called that oh oop
the vacuums
he's gonna use the agonizer audio
mr ross hand over your agonizer
but yeah so all right what was that my
glasses i don't know
what'd you do to my glasses um i hid
them
okay no they were right there and then
that was the last back to the kitchen
with you
maybe he doesn't know what he's doing
half the time they really aren't here
he really he needs to have this like
stapled to his face
because he's always losing him all the
time like he puts he takes him off and
like puts him down on the bed and then
like five minutes later he's like wear
my glasses
wear my glasses and he's like feeling
around on the [ __ ] bed i don't know
he takes him he takes him out in the
other room and then leaves him out there
and then forgets
spock has the glasses maybe he does yes
box stole your glass see i wanted to get
him some kind of either hat or necklace
or something
but first of all i didn't want to tape
anything to him because i
was afraid that it would rip like yeah
make sure i don't want to do that
yeah and we didn't really go anywhere
the had like birthday stuff like hats
and
i don't know like i was thinking like
hawaiian lei would be cool or something
oh yeah yeah
okay party spot but but then he's like
he'll just come in he'll come in
that i wanted to get him some kind of
like party head or necklace or something
but i didn't want to
either rip the i didn't want to tape it
and rip the cardboard
and we didn't really go to a party store
but it's all good
yeah whatever i don't know what happened
to my [ __ ] you can't find your glasses
oh here it is hanging inside that wire
that's some weird shape no it probably
just fell off when you were [ __ ] with
the cake and it just fell off
it just happened to fall off right there
all right all right so i was doing i'm
in between cake bites yeah but we gotta
have to [ __ ] do presents
i know oh we're gonna do presents yeah
okay well we'll hand me a present and
then i'll take a bite
well first of all we've got cards well
yeah now you're telling me
here what am i where oh thank you we're
doing a show all right well
i have my card like i said there's one
more gift thank you
yeah thanks and there's one more thing
and then the card
yeah i'm just keeping on the presents
there's
oh my gosh don't worry about it the
card's like kind of a present
this special one oh no
oh my god oh my god
oh [ __ ] look at this you guys
can i come over for a btk
bite that cake
holy [ __ ] i still do it opposite every
time
oh thank you so much okay if you missed
the cut out man if you missed the cutout
you you what'd you do just joined the
show
yeah who oh he's going what's the cutout
oh
it's mirror universe spot yeah that's
the evil spot that was
that was sophie's presence yeah yeah
he's gonna like lurk there in the
background and judge you
that's popping out of the top of my head
it's cause i'm mirror kirk [ __ ] might
order you
you are very much like mary universe
carrick kind of stop it
okay here's michael okay i want to open
this one did you write anything like
embarrassing in here no okay
i didn't everybody has found the cards
with like the little kitties
yep that's a pookie card yep
wow they all look like pookie they all
look like pooky yeah i have another card
too from
tammy that also has
another pokey card yep
the more gray hair you have the cute
that is a different car didn't it
it is yeah i thought it was yeah because
i didn't have the other one on me
yeah well remember the other one she had
like the the chinese food box on here
okay
why don't you um grab a present oh wait
wait i want to do this other card too
okay
look tammy who was uh often in the
comments i don't know i
haven't seen her in there yeah she also
found a pookie card
so she had the the kitties on her name
was smokey but obviously it's pookie
right so she put pookie thinks you're
looking a little bit older a little
grayer and a little droopier
and inside then again pookie licks her
own butt
so maybe don't listen to pokey she does
like her own butt i've seen her do it
so thank you very much tammy i also have
to say too that
she sent me a really really sweet letter
i don't want to read the whole thing
because it's kind of personal
but um she also sent me some cash with
this little note on it that said
vodka fund and guess what i bought some
vodka with it today
and here it is right in this class
all right so now we're going to do
birthday presents somebody sent you 50
pounds
i know i saw that n dk what's this yeah
dk
ml i don't know it doesn't have a real
name i think it's dan from yeah
he's one of our patrons yeah appreciate
thanks very much um and i also wanted to
give a shout out to you like before i do
the presents i wanted to shout out our
new patron aaron
so thank you very much also i got a
whole bunch of paypal
donations i got some last night when i
was doing the strange realities thing i
got like some money in my tip jar
and i also got some from some of you
guys so i'd like to thank
melanie logan rick daniel
and sandra or sandra i wish somebody i
wish she would tell me how you pronounce
that because i feel bad that i have to
say sandra or sandra like every time she
can pronounce it either way
um so okay and oh i also want to say
thank you very much ken and i just saw
you there
yeah see i said it was i said it was dan
um that
uh that he sent us hh home
yeah so that btk has somebody to hang
out with and talk about serial killing
they can like compare notes and whatnot
yeah i'll move them up on something as
soon as i get it and
also thank you very much louie who i
think is also in the comments today too
he sent us
another special edition blu-ray of
gremlins
so thank you very much all you guys i am
just
overwhelmed with all the love
all the love that is coming from all of
you guys
these are all from me okay so i get to
open the open presents okay i'm going to
open the presents
there you go there you go for their
purchasing
i had to approve them
you have four more yeah yeah yeah you
can just see their tiny little heads and
as funny as that is
to just see their like little bitty
heads like bobbing around
let me keep that oh my god this looks
exciting this looks exciting
[Laughter]
it says hell yeah
oh my god what the okay
hold on hold on hold on hold on three
three more oh my god
yeah it's a shining game holy [ __ ]
yeah i didn't even know this existed
yeah neither did we
what is this it's a shining board game
you guys look at look at look at now you
guys have to play this with me it popped
off
i will but yeah that is so [ __ ] cool
popped up on a shelf at one of the
stores and sophie goes tom look at that
and i saw it and i was like oh
yeah i made it now that's awesome i
figured it might also inspire you on
some of your own games
yeah because i do all my own games all
the time too and i didn't even know that
they had one based on the shining and
that is [ __ ] rad
holy crap oh my god here we go
we're gonna play that later i have like
a bunch of games i have
like gloom that's a card game and i have
like
i think i have one called goth but that
might be in the attic you know what that
is
oh i know what this is i can fee i can
feel the smush you always ask what they
want
you told me you don't well yeah
sometimes well
well i always ask you because he likes
practical gifts he doesn't really like
he wants
[ __ ] he can use yeah tools or something
yeah he's like give me a tool or give me
something for my gun or something
yay look it's 39 i think this is the
last box that they're gonna do you guys
all you mst 3k fans out there because
there are actually 12 more episodes but
they couldn't get the
rights to the movies um but yeah so
factory's been doing all these i have
almost all of them at this point
now that i have 39 i think i have like
five more box sets i have to get
but uh oh my goodness what's what's this
that's the last one
this is the last one okay there's one oh
this
this also feels intriguing
[Laughter]
okay just whip it up well i'm trying to
rip on it you're never gonna say that
i'm not trying to save it
oh man oh man okay
oh man look it
look it it's a baby yoga
i think it's adorable and it's funny
because we were at publix the other day
and they had like the baby yoda cereal
like on the way out of the thing and i
was just like look that baby own a
cereal it's like i almost kind of want
that
so you guys got me a baby i'm not a fan
of human babies and it makes human baby
noises
it's got those black eyes and it's like
it's not fuzzy or anything
it's way cuter he's like cuter than a
human baby but he acts like one
that's true so that's that's just no
except he has magic powers
yeah but he cries like a human baby and
i can't i can't do that
i can't do that as soon as that happened
i'm like
no no it's like he should have just felt
like a little kitten or like there were
some other
animals in the mandalorian that were
kind of cute i forget what it was but
there's a couple other ones i was like
oh that's cute you know what honestly
the droids i find the droids
way cooler and cuter the droids are
pretty cute i gotta say
i mean anything that's like kind of
little i'm always team droid
other than like i said human babies
human babies are not cute
and that's what happened with animal
babies are cute like monster babies are
cute like stuff like that but
human babies human babies not so much
they all kind of look like scrunched up
little
man it feels hot in here and i know the
ac is on well
i'm sorry you should tell you that
that's cool they're going like that
feels great in here it feels
just great completely comfortable
yeah sandra says another stuffed animal
beijing can carry away in the middle of
the night i don't know that one's almost
as big as her
that one's kind of although um she took
my
bride of frankenstein doll which is
about half her size
and she has hidden it somewhere and i
have no idea where it is
i haven't usually she just like she
takes them and she just like leaves them
in the middle of the floor
like in the hall or in the living room
or whatever but that bride of
frankenstein i have not seen for like a
week and a half
so she must have stowed that one
somewhere because that one's like
i said i'm gonna have to check through
my suitcases because she's hanging out
in my room a lot i'm like
if she put that thing like in my stuff
she might have
she might be like see i knew i was right
it was 73 in here
what's wrong with 73 oh no no no no no
no
no no no no no 71 no 70 to 71. 73 that's
hot we can't have those two extra
degrees
those two extra degrees sometimes it
gets up a little bit higher so he said
tom's having a hot flash
yeah also it is it's menopause it's a
thing
it's a thing i've never heard of it
oracle said i'm now imagining beijing
and pookie teaming up to steal baby yoda
i'm gonna keep baby over yoda up high
yeah
you know the cats are gonna be
interested in that though they'll be
like what it is cats go that's a face i
know i'm facing a feast
i'm gonna get all up in yeah they you
know they they like they know that they
like the babies
but yeah so that's why like sophie's
laughing because she she actually got
some video i'll show it in the on the
break
she got some video of beijing because i
told you guys beijing
just as soon as she came over baby was
like i love
you and she's just like rolling all over
her stuff
and climbing all over and everything
like that it's really really funny
but yeah so uh we gonna start talking
about the actual well tell them what to
tell them about what this is the topic
is all right
so here's another thing folks what's
that tom had to drop his nuts on this
[ __ ] show
okay because the shows have been running
four or five
six hours long and by the time the
shit's over with man we're [ __ ]
toasted
all right well we have another show
we're trying to make after this one
it invited us to be on it it's the zoom
party for
like the online zoom party for the
people that did the strange realities
conference
so it's not like formal or anything it's
just like a hangout yeah
so it's not starting till 10 we might go
do that and like i said
i just see how things go i had to give
my presentation last night
from 10 40 to 11 40. and who boy was i
tired
yeah wow because i think i woke up at
five or six
the morning of and i think i woke up at
seven this morning so i'm like pretty
tired right now too but you know
just gotta keep on keeping on yeah
there's almonds in that
yeah it's good it's good it is it's
really good yeah it needs banana
no it doesn't need banana nothing needs
banana
okay let's let's establish that right
here
nothing needs banana ever okay all right
they're just kind of like raisins
nothing needs raisins
either yeah she hates banana i just i
don't
hate actual bananas like i can i can eat
an actual banana like every now and then
thank you very much judd
can i get a t-shirt for jenny's birthday
of course you can yes
just tell me what size you want and what
design you want and we will uh print one
out for any
address and all that other kind of stuff
because i don't think i have your
address
but um how drunk are y'all not yet i
only just started drinking
i'm still sipping a protein shake so i
haven't even touched alcohol yet
i'm being really really good yeah yeah
it's like yeah see this is
this is my first this is my first one so
all right so yeah i'm not even
i'm not even there yet yeah yeah don't
worry about me guys
don't worry about it i really gotta
[ __ ]
we'll get there eventually but yeah well
yeah worry about my second drink i'll
probably
be filming yeah we're we're old and
seasoned drunk
so uh yeah it takes us a while because
even last night before i did the show
like i s i drank from what 7 to 9
30 and then i just stopped so i had two
big ones but then i was like sober by
the time i went on
because i said i got to read some [ __ ]
so for an hour
so the topic this week which i thought
like i said we'll do a fun one
and this was the one that was
overwhelmingly the favorite like
on the patreon poll i actually had just
put in the poll charlie no face the
charlie no face
legend but then i was kind of like
reading about the legend and i was like
well i don't know if that's like enough
to like talk about
like have a whole show around so i
decided to do
urban legends that kind of turned out to
be true
as the charlie new face legend did so i
want to talk about
i actually had one extra case that i
took off that i'll do on another show
but we'll do like charlie no face we'll
do like the bunny man like bunny man
bridge
um that kind of uh the sideshow corpse
and i mean like the sideshow decoration
the turnip variable body all that kind
of stuff
so i have like four i think i have four
or five different cases we can talk
about not like hugely
okay uh you know he's got 52 people in
there
right now that's huge for this show i
know see yeah everybody's going to
celebrate my birthday and also urban
legends because everybody likes urban
legends that's like super fun
all right so kanavasan says uh
oh michael shafer i do actually like
raisin bread hmm
okay i'm not i'm not a fan
i like reasons when they're in like
indian food but
other than that yeah myth all right yeah
khan's never heard of these legends
yeah these are man's lands
that's that's the mexican spelling
j y and j y g can be get kind of
confusing sometimes
legends yeah well these are i've heard
of them
so this is going to be that's a good one
that's a good that's a good one these
are all american legends except for
there's one scottish one i'm trying not
to talk for a minute so i can chew
yeah you done with that cake no you guys
no i got one more piece that's what i
said i'm trying to
all right take your time i wanted you to
talk so i could go ahead and take your
time i'm talking
okay i'll talk don't put all that in
your mouth jenny
damn damn
i did not say that it was your
imagination it's my imagination it's
your imagination i didn't say that i got
a dirty imagination yeah of course let
me get that [ __ ] play
you did sam yeah it was it was it's on
tape
yeah i just like you know he just he
just wanted to set that up
i kind of walked into it though i was
just trying to like finish the cake you
know
look at spock every time i turn my head
i'm like who's that back there oh it's
sexy mirror spock that's who it is that
happened to call with him when i walked
in the bedroom
we ended up putting him behind the door
because i thought you'd walk by i'm like
i don't think you're gonna see them but
yeah i it's like i don't usually go over
there over there
and i wouldn't have ever looked behind
the door he was actually in his box
until yesterday i pulled them out
and unfolded them where'd you guys get
where'd you guys get them from i ordered
them
oh okay i ordered it like
a couple weeks ago so i was glad it
showed up on time at least one thing did
i know that's super look at him in there
laughing i knew tom would go there
yeah dj maniacs jenny does not like
eating on camera i do not
well just because i knew it i told him
that i was like she's not gonna like
that
well it's like it's all right as long as
like i kind of put because i don't want
like everybody like in america like
looking at my [ __ ] chewed up food you
know what i'm saying yeah
or like was seeing like icing on my
mouth or i'll find a spot for baby yoda
and all kinds of stuff
yeah we're gonna have to we're gonna
have to like have to rearrange [ __ ] back
there we're gonna have to put a little
shelf like right behind
raise baby yoda up a little bit you
could be like floating yeah
you wouldn't be able to see baby yoda
right now because sophie's sitting there
but when you know
oh i can leave i mean no i get my baby
in my seat i'll make you cradle baby
yoda
no
ain't cradling [ __ ] but yeah cradling
and best
breastfeeding baby yoda
that's a nightmare [ __ ] a million hits
man
you know what kind of money rolling you
know there's some porn of some
big breasted chick with a breastfeeding
baby yeah dressed up in a in a yoda
type outfit or one of them twilight
outfits yeah yeah
i bet you i'm not gonna get i'm not
gonna look yeah but
i'm sure that there is some weird [ __ ]
well that's rule 34 it's rule 34
whatever there is what if it exists
there's porn of it
yes it did see the gundam robot
yeah see sandra gets it she says i
understand it's like eating on the first
date i always order something that
doesn't make a mess
no spaghetti no salad etc yeah exactly
yeah the japanese built a gigantic
gundam robot that was a long time ago
though
it's a statue but it looks it moves a
little bit it's like a piece of work a
piece of heart it's big it's probably
about five stories tall
wait five stories oh yeah it's huge is
that what you just said yeah
it's huge actual size those giant
gundam robots i didn't see that i didn't
see that
we didn't see it because you didn't see
it it's been around for a while that was
deep
yeah i think they actually built that in
the early 2000s
i think
that video has been around for a while
they built like a okay like a rocket
hanger for it and everything instead in
there
smoke coming out of it it moves a little
bit oh guys we're working on it
yeah it looks just now right out of the
anime are they gonna are they gonna also
build like a life-size
godzilla at some point i don't know they
do all kinds of crazy [ __ ] over in japan
yeah michael shafer just says hey tom
did you ever see the japanese godzilla
christmas tree
no i didn't see that i have not seen
that either now look it up
and dan also says people have some odd
fetishes i was reading a story from a
guy
who [ __ ] a block of cheese on reddit
damn
sure he didn't make it up well what kind
of cheese are we talking about maybe he
like
half melted it first or something i was
gonna say well maybe it was brie
you know maybe because the first thing i
thought
was here you don't want like a block of
right first thing i thought it was like
cheddar and i was like wait you probably
had to cut a hole in that first
i mean you know it's not like soft and
squishy like pie was it warm said work
that's what i'm saying that's very good
it's got to be something like that
wang channel his name is wang he he
posted something about some internet
some internet legend some girl who
farted on cakes
oh that's a thing that yeah like she
said so far i think i've
i think i've been tricked into seeing
something like that yeah
i've seen bits of it and i'm like
on cakes yeah so that's a thing now yeah
well i think i think it was a thing
for a long time ago that just comes back
comes back right now then yeah
early like i think it was early like or
maybe like late 90s
internet meme type deal that was going
on not memes but you know
viral videos or whatever why would you
think of those two things
specifically in tandem with one another
see that's just some crazy thing
yeah pretty girl sitting on a cake
farting on it
that's his porn that's how i'm imagining
you do you bro
that's how i'm imagining that it [ __ ]
i'm imagining the genesis of the fart
cake
you know i'm figuring that's how it
starts the genesis of
the fight yeah genesis of the fart cake
that's the episode of doctor who
doctor
not gonna lie i'd probably watch that
that's the old tom baker
tom baker [ __ ] doctor who
yeah victor garcia says who the [ __ ]
farts on cakes pies yes
not cakes you got that beautiful
frosting
yeah yeah like that one it looks like a
wedding cake probably that's how i'm
imagining it i didn't see it
yeah it might just be like a [ __ ]
duncan hines cake yeah
i feel like it i don't know it would
have to be like a fancy like the one you
just pick off the shelf that's already
made
i mean you'd think that you'd think that
part of the fetish would be
that you were like sullying something
that was beautiful and
good-looking and sweet and everything so
you'd think you'd want the prettiest
cake imaginable and then just have some
chick come over and fart on it
it's just crazy [ __ ] the people i had
speaking of farting
some chuck tingle [ __ ] it is yeah yeah
that that'll be his next one
yeah pounded in the butt by
the gate of the muscle and farting on
cakes
i you know what in in the show that we
did the other day we were talking about
chuck tangled i was reading off we
didn't even get into like his 2020 [ __ ]
and like some of the titles in there
were like the funniest ever
like my favorite one i don't know why
this was my favorite
but my favorite one was these boots are
made for pounding and that's just what
they'll do
one of these days these boots are going
to pound you in the butt
just straight up and i just laughed and
left
oh my god now speaking of farting i had
a dream lesson i already told tom this
earlier
i had a dream last night that beijing
was in a room and she kept farting
and i think in the dream that she could
talk and she was like really embarrassed
about it she was like oh my god i can't
believe because we were like being like
what the [ __ ] she's like
and we like closed her in the room and
then i dreamed that your mom was giving
him
giving her tums for some reason i was
just kind of like
okay i don't think you can give thumbs
to a cat but yeah she was like she was
embarrassed about like all the farting
i don't know it was very weird so uh so
yeah so we're going to talk about
some urban legends that turned out to be
true sort of hold on one second before i
got off onto this got people talking
about doctor who
and tom baker doctor who
doctor who is [ __ ] geeky as [ __ ] all
right i mean that's even geekier than
[ __ ] star trek and i love star trek
all right but the most ultimate
the ultimate doctor who was the 70s
doctor who with tom baker it was kind of
kind of like up there with star trek the
original
series in in in legend-ness
so if you want to see doctor who get the
old doctor who
from tom baker something like
there are in they are all in order too
there's like a
a story arc and it's got the doctor has
the hottest
sidekicks during that one too he had
leela
had sarah i think her name was sarah
jane was in it yeah there's a bunch a
bunch of different little sidekicks that
he had
they never really come out and say
whether or not he's hitting
but you kind of think he is hidden okay
that's just not really the type of show
it was but
uh no you want to see tom you want to
see something like revenge of the
cybermen
or you want to see doctor who in the
genesis of the dialects
or you want to see doctor who in the
towns of wang chang so the good [ __ ]
it was cheesy as [ __ ] but it was just
well written
and you could tell that it was from the
heart that they cared about
the the the series you know it's good
movie good series good series
yeah it says there's a doctor who
channel on pluto tv i wonder do they
show like the new ones or the old ones
or
the new ones that aren't aren't as good
i haven't seen the new ones
the david tennant ones are all right but
nah tom becker was it christopher
ecclestone.com yeah
i like it i like him uh he was okay
doctor who i think it was only a season
or two
but no none of the new stuff he impales
in comparison to the
into the geekiness that was you know
this
tom baker doctor who i remember my
cousin watching because it was like
highly detailed stories that all
fit together and they were kind of a big
story arc to them
and tom tom baker was a really good
storyteller so he could sell that
that character you believe that he was
the doctor the newer guys i never really
believed that they were the doctor
yeah i'm talking about yeah i don't see
what you're saying tom was a [ __ ]
was he he he was a he was a dude
installing cabinets
yeah and then he got that job he was an
actor but he was a carpenter really
that's how he
like harrison ford yeah he's like
harrison ford so he was just a working
man and when he got that role he really
put his heart into it
or at least it seemed to be he was
putting heart into it and he
i think he helped create that character
it's kind of in the way that leonard
nimoy created spock
yeah you know so it all comes back
there's really only going to be one
spock
that's leonard de moy yeah i mean i do
well i do like the guy
um zachary quinto or whoever that plays
him in the new ones
yeah um he's he's good but you know it's
like he said that's leonard character
yeah i mean he was very instrumental in
like you know putting that together so
yeah it's like you know other people can
play him but it's just not the same
um okay so are you ready to talk about
urban legends though let's do it
where are we half an hour yeah yeah well
no we're like 46 minutes then we have
damn [ __ ] burning up the time go
ahead
and you wonder why the shows are five
hours long but yeah
yeah he's blaming it on me i know but um
yeah all right so the first one let's
talk about because this is the one that
won in the poll
is the legend of charlie no face also
known as
the green man now this was a legend
and i guess it kind of went around it's
still current nowadays i guess people
still uh
talk about it at least according to uh
what i could discover
but kind of the heyday was back in the
50s and 60s
and this is in uh western pennsylvania
now the legend says that this is
essentially like a boogie man he was
like a guy
that would walk um down these like
lonely streets in western pennsylvania
like in the middle of the night
and that one that he didn't have a face
hence the name charlie no face
and two that he would usually be glowing
green
and the legend was that he had been in
some sort of industrial accident
or had been struck by lightning or
something like that
and so he glowed green and didn't have a
face and he would um
kind of walk around these lonely streets
in the middle of the night and would
attack
people that were like parking parked and
like making out in their cars and
[ __ ] like that that's a good way to get
shot it is
well well yeah that that part of the
that part of the legend is actually not
true okay but
the um the guy that they are talking
about the guy this legend is based on
was absolutely a real
person his name was raymond robinson
now he didn't glow green that i know of
however he didn't have a face really
you guys want to see a picture like he
was he was in the thing but uh yeah
there's a picture of him right here
oh wait i think i have seen that yeah
yeah
i forget what happened if it was an
accident yeah it was
what ended up happening yeah jesus
christ
in 1919 he was eight years old
and he was like an eight-year-old kid he
was climbing up an electrical pole
like i guess to get a bird's nest and he
got
shocked with 11 000 volts of electricity
burned him up and it like set him flying
to the ground
um it basically burnt most of his face
off
uh and his arms and uh so it just left
holes
like where his nose and eyes were it's
amazing he even survived it
yeah they said it was he could still uh
hear and he could still talk
um they said even after that accident he
was still like a real cheerful
dude which i i just couldn't see no
he didn't well he didn't have any eyes
oh it blew his eyes his eyes were blown
out
they were just like holes there man what
that was when
1919 i'm amazed that i don't want to
sound
cruel or anything i'm amazed that they
let him live in 1919.
yeah i mean well he still had all his
mental faculties and they said he was
still like really like
in good spirits and everything i heard
that it was kind of common for doctors
to to if somebody was severely in
uh injured and like they figured they
would be worthless for the rest of their
life
yeah to [ __ ] give them a lethal
injection on the slide yikes
to make sure that they i guess if he was
i want to say
okay it's just his face that got burned
right yeah yeah but in the face in one
arm
you walk around and stuff like in 1919
they would have considered that
a person like that to not have a future
that i would have i would thought they
would have put him down especially it
was country
people were uglier back then though they
could probably underaccept it more than
nowadays that's how i think about it
like well if a person was blind that
you're pretty much
condemned to poverty maybe he was from a
wealthy family
well i don't know he seems to have had
like people taking care of him yeah
so he lived um you know he lived in the
same area like his whole life
um and he lived up until his 70s
actually
and what he would do was for money he uh
was a craftsman he would make
um like wallets and belts and stuff like
out of leather
and then he would sell them so he had
like his own little business even though
he was blind he was doing that
now because of the way his face looked
um
he really liked to go for walks but he
didn't like to
frighten people with his face so he
would go for walks in the middle of the
night like on these really like
abandoned country roads so people that
were
driving around these country roads at
night and didn't know
the story of what had happened to him
all they would know is they were driving
around in the dark and they see like a
dude with no face
like walking down the street and they
would flip out so there was like this
whole urban legend
that rose up about it even though it was
a real dude he never like
chased anyone's car he didn't glow or
anything like that although i think the
thing about
glowing green it's weird because the
urban legend said oh he was struck by
lightning or he was an industrial
accident which is kind of close to what
happened to him he got electrocuted
so i guess like somebody did remember
that detail
and so that kind of got incorporated
into the legend as well but then like he
would see
you know people would see him and they
didn't know who he was or they didn't
know he was a real guy so they thought
he was like some kind of like boogeyman
or something yeah
um and yeah so he so he would just walk
around in the middle of the night
and uh he usually walked around uh state
road
351 route 351 now
i guess that some people were like
actually really nice some people had
actually like spoke to him and stuff
said he was like the nicest dude ever
um but of course teenagers uh you know
in back then
just as nowadays are [ __ ] and uh so
some of them would
give him a ride somewhere and then like
drop him off someplace where he didn't
know where it was because he was blind
that he couldn't find his way back
um you know they would throw [ __ ] at him
and do crap like that but you know some
people were like really nice to him too
and everybody that spoke to him said he
was like a really nice dude
and like i said he made like wallets and
belts and thing and things for like
people around the house
that that was how he made money and um
some of the teenagers that grew up
around there they said when they
figured out who he was they would go out
and like take him beer and cigarettes
and stuff like if they knew he was going
to be walking around out there so i
thought that was kind of cool
but they didn't actually know too much
about his life other than like what he
did and stuff because he was real
quiet and he just kind of like kept
himself to himself because of what his
face looked like
um but they said that he died in uh
1985 and he was 74 years old
and he died of natural causes so like i
said this whole urban legend about
charlie no face
that was a real guy wow and uh they
still
as far as i know the urban legend still
persists to this day although like i
said a lot of them call him the green
man
that seemed like it was more common
because he was supposed to glow green
even though he didn't actually
even though charlie no faces a lot i can
see how like kids would be scared
of someone like that yeah you know
you're probably trying to walk at night
to avoid people right
because you know you're like i'll just
keep to myself and do my little walk
but then if someone happened to chance
upon him it was like
yeah and that seems like pretty much
what happened
and then like all this because all these
teenagers would go out if i dare each
other like i'll go out dare a little kid
like i'll go go out and find you yeah
we're gonna go see the faceless
yeah yeah and i guess he was eight when
the injury happened so he was already
established in the community and his
parents took care of him so
i guess they didn't put him down i mean
the reason why i'm thinking that is
because
in mississippi and you know my dad told
me this there was a state hospital there
that went all the way back to the
[ __ ] 1920s and 1930s
and if you sent a kid to that state
hospital chances of that kid ever coming
out about
zero yeah and it was like for people
that were it was for
it was for kids and for and for people
that were really
you know in real bad health in other
words you know they were born with
[ __ ]
bad really bad deformities or you know
what i mean mentally just totally
screwed up
and evidently their their life
expectancy in that state hospital wasn't
very long
and if i remember correctly from what my
dad
believed i don't know how he knew it but
he thought that they gave him lethal
injections eventually
it wouldn't surprise me because it's not
like i mean they did all kind of
horrible [ __ ]
like to people and i think he was
talking about the 30s 30s and 40s and
the 50s
that's what i think is what he was
talking about i mean even some
underhanded like
even up until the 60s they were doing
like yeah they [ __ ] up [ __ ]
it was silence well they had eugenics
laws
too and and i don't know
well maybe it wasn't eugenics laws but
they had
eugenic ideas you know what i mean and i
think they
like it wouldn't be legal i don't think
they have i think that kind of [ __ ]
maybe not killing them but they probably
sterilize them
they were doing that [ __ ] they were
doing that yeah they were saying they
would kill them yeah
but they weren't he said it from what i
remember when he told me they weren't
killing them
legally they were killing them illegally
well they were probably sterilizing them
you know like this one's been around too
long the family's never going to reclaim
this kid and
yeah he's been here for two or three
years here give him that
that'll not well the thing is it's like
who's going to check
nobody that's the sad thing like no
one's going to check so it's not like
they'd ever get going they had new ones
coming
and limited resources you know limited
state resources so they had to keep the
population down
and they would have been considered in
that day and
time useless eaters you know what i mean
and there's limited staff
so they had ways of killing these kids
maybe
they were mostly kids yeah but like this
guy a physical deformity i think is
different because
he other than looking weird it sounds
like he could talk could you talk
yeah yeah so other than looking weird it
seems like he could be a functioning
member
yeah he was he had you know he made
things he had a job i think
because it happened when he was eight i
think that's why he survived
had that happened to him when he was two
or three
and the parents were very poor from
mississippi he'd have been euthanized
i think he'd been euthanized they did
[ __ ] like that it wasn't even legal
they just did it well yeah that's
country doctors
that's what i'm saying they're like oh
it wasn't legal
you know i mean the parents would leave
they were like i can't let i can't
burden this family you know
and this this boy ain't gonna make it so
you know they walk out of the room
give that kid a lethal overdose of
morphine you know
and evidently that's just what they did
well yeah like i said it wouldn't
surprise me right i mean because there
wasn't really any oversight and like i
said if somebody died
like if somebody that had like some kind
of disability like that died in a mental
hospital or they didn't have any family
it's like nobody was gonna like
in mississippi there was oversight but
the oversight was your cousin
right yeah so there was essentially
a favorite was your cousin and all the
law enforcement were people you grew up
with
exactly there is no oversight that's
what i'm saying right
that's effectively no it would have been
like did you take care of that since i
couldn't do it as you did the right
thing it'd have been like that
yeah yeah and he even did the accent
yeah he got him recording
he did the right thing things got to
move on
gotta move on they'll try again they'll
have another kid
they'll try again that's just the way
you know
well back then it's like you know
especially in rural areas yeah
a lot of your kids didn't maybe didn't
live yeah very long because of course
that's just an expense right there yeah
everyone had to be useful yeah yeah
right yeah
they can't work on the farm they weren't
useful then you were dead
they can't work on the farm you're a
little kid yeah yeah
exactly all right so uh let's talk about
the bunny man
now this one uh this one it's
interesting because the legend
it does have some basis in reality but i
think the legend kind of went way off
the rails and like you know incorporated
a bunch of other things it didn't have
anything to do with it
but this um the bunnyman legend comes
from
fairfax county virginia
now this is apparently it's been around
for at least 40 years if not longer
and um i think it's still pretty uh
prevalent nowadays because i saw a lot
of stuff about it bunnyman the bunnyman
bridge all that kind of stuff so
like i said it's virginia so
the the story is and this isn't exactly
what happened but this is what the urban
legend is
so apparently sometime in the early 20th
century like some undisclosed time
period
there were some woods that were in the
middle of um the town of clifton
and uh fairfax station and now
supposedly
there was a mental asylum there we're
back to the mental asylums again
now what supposedly happened was that
the mental asylum
closed and they put all of the patients
into a bus and they were going to send
them they were going to take them to
lorton prison
now supposedly on the way there the bus
swerved and crashed
now most of the people that were in the
bus
the mental patients escaped um
but they ended up getting caught except
for one
a guy named douglas griffin
now the story goes that while the cops
were looking for this one
absconded mental patient they found
like a trail of a bunch of like
bunnies that had been like gutted and
were like half eaten
and were like kind of hanging in trees
and [ __ ] like that
and uh hanging from the from a bridge
which is now known as the bunny man
bridge
even though it's uh not its actual name
so apparently the cops looked for this
guy for like a really long time but they
never found him
and then supposedly that same year on
halloween night
they found um there were a bunch of
teenagers that were
hanging out underneath this particular
bridge and
at midnight they all got attacked
now the next morning so the story goes
they were all found
hanging from the bridge with their guts
hanging out just like the bunnies were
now the legend says that nowadays
if you go to the bunny man bridge on a
halloween night then the same [ __ ] is
gonna happen
to you i ain't buying it well yeah now
i'm saying
now even though i call this show urban
legend now this is
you know the [ __ ] about the hanging from
the bridge and all this that is not true
but the [ __ ] about the bunny man is may
be true
so so here's uh the actual story
now the thing about it though is that i
saw this one paper
that was about this urban legend and he
kind of went into
he's like okay now for one thing the
mental asylum where they said that it
was there was never a mental asylum
there
and you know there's nothing in the
record about a but a bus a butt crash
minecraft a butt crash there's some
chuck tickle [ __ ]
that's right crash there's a butt going
down the road it leaves the road goes
airborne and smacks into another ass
like crap crash yeah and it makes a
noise collision
yeah and it's men's asses it's men's
butts well if you didn't
then yeah you know sometimes i
lose that in the translation when i'm
reading those damn titles i'm thinking
i'm like oh yeah he's talking about
men's ass
i need to [ __ ] settle down you need
to settle that
because you were getting all in yeah
[Music]
turned gay by the butt cardi
or michael shearer says or it smacks
into your windshield so you get a good
view of it
chuck tingle's butt crashes dance
he's trying to put himself that's trying
to put himself into into tingles
[ __ ] trying to put himself into tingle
tude which is like
the position of being tangled and he
assumes that he stands or
he imagines himself standing at the
intersection watching a crash
between one ass and another ass and
their men's asses
that's a [ __ ] that's a that's a chuck
tango book right there man it's a good
job
i just yeah i just had like a mental
picture of like hats
going like this and then there's like
fireworks and it forces you to become
gay
just just witnessing it just witnessing
it
you're forced well if it was chuck
taylor it would be like an existential
crisis i remember like
the dread of becoming gay or something i
don't know
is that that sounds logical to you
with your sexy ass boobs
he says it sounds logical pound it in
the checks out pound it in the butt by
mirror
one of my favorite things is the person
or persons who made like the kind of
super cut
of all of the scenes of kirk and spock
from the original series like looking
lovingly at one another
it was just like this like long gay long
gay super cut
i've liked the two of them that's what i
mean yeah it's funny
and it's like it's really good and i'm
like wow somebody spent a lot of time on
this i'm afraid
sophie's in the comments section talking
about her struggle to find her
i'm answering people's questions i'm
being social i'm doing it right be
social be social
being social letting jenny do her thing
i'm keeping my
conversation down here yeah the show
keeps rolling sophie's selfie is totally
normal she's cool
that is that is the furthest from the
truth no one's totally normal
good to go she's good go ahead oh okay
she's she's talking
you know what you can't really can't
really see can you pop it up i need to
get me
do you want me to do you want me to get
rid of the of the ticker
do you not see them better sorry i'll
just raise that right a little bit i
mean you can
it doesn't okay would that be easier
then you have to worry about easier to
raise
like stacked easier to raise them up you
have the leaning tower of cds
gotta give these guys a damn boost yeah
there's those gotta give them a boost
they're so small come on you guys get up
here with everybody
there you go that's better look at their
little heads
it's wobbling well yeah so your colors
shouldn't be cute but they're really
cute
they are really cute yeah i love i love
how
dapper hh homes is yeah and you know
what they kind of make a good pair
you're right because they both had like
normal lives going on
you know they're like similar yeah in
certain ways not
in the way that yeah hh was like a
businessman
they were all yeah and they were well
loved by the community
veronica says oh dennis needs a whittle
bitty booster seat
yeah they both do they're both like
really shrimpy
so yeah so i was reading a thing about
the the bunny band legend and they said
there were actually like a couple of
like weird murders
that happened around the time period
where the urban legend was kind of like
coming to fruition but
none of them were um really all that
similar like no one was found hanging
from the bridge or anything like that
but i mean there were some weird merge
that happened but
nothing that you know is really like
close to these
they said so another thing too is that
the prison where these mental patients
were supposedly being taken wasn't built
until
later like wasn't built until like after
the you know the legend was supposed to
have taken place
so they so what ended up happening was
like this guy was
just like what the [ __ ] is up with this
bunnyman legend this guy that lived
there he was like a historian or he was
interested in it so he's
so he starts looking back like through
all the records to see
where this where a bunnyman story like
came from
now like i said the urban legend was
like the guy killing bunnies
like not necessarily looking like a
bunny like donnie darko style
but what actually what actually happened
was that
okay so in october of 1970
there was a newspaper report of a guy
who was
uh an air force academy cadet his name
was robert bennett
and him and his girlfriend were sitting
in a car
like making out i guess uh and it was
like right around midnight
near bennett's uncle's house and this
dude
dressed like a rabbit he was wearing
like a white bunny suit
and he came like out of the bushes or
whatever
and he started yelling at them the bunny
started yelling at these two people in
this car
and said you're on private property and
i have your tag number
and then he threw a hatchet through
their car window
which that's weird right
i mean you know so the hatchet missed
them thankfully
but they reported to police as you would
because they're like what the [ __ ] a
dude in a bunny suit just came out like
threw a [ __ ] hatchet at us and
this was in 1970. now two weeks after
that
there was another report so this is only
about a block away from where the first
[ __ ] had happened
so this was um the article this article
came out on halloween
this guy's kind of like the original
killer clown yeah that's what i was
thinking too
yeah that might be like where that came
from dang yeah yeah
he's gonna dress up in a bunny suit
because he's got one
and run around yeah he got it for easter
and then he's gonna do some [ __ ]
stunts and then no one will ever believe
it
i mean why not he's now he's now he's
immortalized yeah so
no one will ever believe the reports
maybe he's the guy that plays the easter
bunny at the mall
i don't know i don't know if there's any
malls around there in 1970 or 1971 or
whatever it inspired donnie darko
that's what i'm saying i think maybe
donnie darko like got the idea for of
frank being in a bunny suit like
from this legend it may be because this
legend's actually pretty well known
so two weeks after the hatchet throwing
incident
there was another guy that was a private
security guard named paul phillips
and he said that he saw same thing he
saw a guy in a bunny suit
and he was standing on the front porch
of a house that had just been built like
nobody lived in it yet but it was
finished
so he said he sees this bunny guy
and he's wearing like it was a gray
black and white bunny costume i don't
know if the first one i thought they
said he had
a white costume did he have the head i
want the ears i think so yeah
in the first case for sure because they
said yeah he had like the big long ears
on now i don't know if the face was
visible because the security guard said
i thought it was a younger guy like 20
years old and i don't know how you'd be
able to tell that if you couldn't see
his face might have just had ears
maybe yeah maybe it was just ears and
then like a like a
fuzzy jumpsuit maybe so so yeah so he's
like so this
bunny guy is like standing on this porch
of this house and he's got an axe like a
little hatchet in his hand
and he says he tried to talk to him like
hey man what's your deal or whatever
and he's like the guy in the bunny suit
started chopping at the
like the porch support which i guess was
made of wood so he just like starts
chopping at it
and then he says to the security guard
he says all you people trespass around
here
if you don't get out of here i'm going
to chop off your head or bust you on the
head i've heard like
two versions let me straighten out the
the comment section okay
they're talking about killer clown now
we're not talking about killer clowns
from outer space
we shouldn't be there
there's a there was a phenomenon
happening
where little black kids were reporting
that they saw
[ __ ] clowns with hatchets and axes
yeah by coming out of the bushes or
standing by the garbage cans
and then they were running and telling
their parents their parents were calling
the cops
i know what it is though it's juggalos
that's i i see
i feel it but you know what though i
feel like that happened in the uk
as well i think they might have juggalos
in the uk yeah you probably get juggled
because
icp there's a band called icp insane
clown posse
all right from detroit they're from
detroit they drink faygo and they do all
that [ __ ] weird [ __ ] and they
it's violent jay and shaggy
the music actually was pretty good i
haven't heard it in a long time i don't
know any other newer stuff
it was [ __ ] hilariously funny and
very self-deprecating yeah and their
fans would dress up
like clowns psychopathic clowns
and pull pranks on people and that's
exactly like they would do
they would they would they would go to
go to the hood
and let little black kids [ __ ] see
them they'd be standing there in a scary
clown
outfit and then they'd probably run you
know before they got their asses shot i
think that's how it started and then
people
copycats were just doing it of course
the news blows everything up and then
they were like literally by me they took
clown costumes off the shelves of
halloween yeah they were banning clowns
so of course you ban
stuff what happens people yeah are like
oh you mean if i dress up like a con
walk down the street at night they're
gonna put me on the news well oh yeah
the giveaway is the black kid element
juggalos and that's what that's what the
fans of icp would go for the black kids
they're mostly white though they're
white the reason why is because in
juggalo mythology they are not allowed
in the hood
they are outcasts of the hood okay so
they're gonna [ __ ] re-invade the hood
all right to make a name for themselves
and get their asses kicked because
they're not cool
they're not even trying to be cool
they're the opposite of being cool
most people hate juggling yeah yeah
they're obviously cool they're nerdy
they're
nervous they're usually like white and
me yeah yeah the reputation is like
trailer
trailers yeah they're not trying to hurt
the kids they just they just want
to scare the kids and have everybody
talk about the juggalos showing up
they would just think it was funny the
running of the jungle the running of the
jungle
they do a gathering every year they did
before yeah somebody somebody said they
still do it
i saw i saw footage from it it's
hilarious yeah and they go to they also
used to go to the french quarter
down bourbon street in new orleans they
would show up there all the time
and get their asses kicked they just get
their ass because like i said everybody
has trouble yeah
yeah most people well the thing is them
getting their asses kicked they'd go
there to get their asses kicked they
were kind of like
massachusetts they were masochistic
because most of the [ __ ] icp songs
are about getting your ass kicked
well i guess they've had a lot of it so
they're trying to get like more
experience trying to get
their next album you know what i mean
yeah yeah it's all funny
it's all humor it's not they're not
violent well
they throw [ __ ] yeah
that's cheap so i'm pretty sure at one
point they were classified as a
not a terrorist group there was
something they were on a watch list
they were for a while they might be off
now right because there were certain
clubs in michigan
that wouldn't let them play or they had
to have heightened security because they
were afraid there was going to be like
gang activity and they would throw
[ __ ] soda everywhere we had this soda
yeah in michigan called faygo you could
get an entire two liter of it for about
25. you can get it here too it's just
like red pop
yes but it was just super cheap back in
the day
and it wasn't bad it was pretty good i
liked the peach
uh i liked it the cola was [ __ ] it
had a really
cheap corn syrupy taste you could get a
whole two liter for 25 cents
think about that [ __ ] a whole two liter
for 25. and then you could get cans and
bottles for like [ __ ] next to nothing
and they had a [ __ ] flavor called
arctic sun that was
[ __ ] tasted like [ __ ] it tasted like
[ __ ]
it was blue and i could you couldn't
tell if it was mint or orange or both
or and and and imagine you took sprite
and tried to flavor it with [ __ ] mint
and orange at the same time no
no it's like drinking orange juice
afterwards
yeah it's like what the [ __ ] are they
thinking it was like the worst one
the rest of them were okay though the
your [ __ ] tongue would be all burnt
after you
i feel like the orange figure the orange
figo's okay
yeah and the red one's okay i think it
was worse when we were kids
they had one called red pop that's what
i mean that's the one
that was all right yeah red pop red pop
was [ __ ]
i think i had it at the moment it was
like red cream soda from what i remember
i don't know i don't drink pops but
yeah it's a michigan thing so it's a
real [ __ ] michigan yeah i'm not a big
soda drinker person
yeah faygo and verners the ginger albert
nurses michigan
so it's our claim to fame well verner's
is really good
i have to say yeah i like it i don't
like that either but
i like j if i'm going to drink soda it's
going to be either ginger ale or root
beer
i'm not you know i'm not really into
coke or pepsi or anything
or sprite if i have to or maybe orange
soda yeah
other than that i don't he likes to go
buy soda at the store and i don't
yeah i love soda i don't ever like
divine like man if i'm gonna like have
the calories i'd rather like eat
something good mexico is very confused
over what a juggalo is
it's okay it's not worth it
like you can like i know a lot of people
that like the music but they don't like
juggalo
juggalo is an icp fan yeah but this is a
certain
super fan yeah it's an icp super fan
it's not something you really want to be
it's like it's these dudes that dress up
like
they're rappers for rap fans white rap
fans that dress up
like cheap two-bit clowns two-bit clowns
get beat up and [ __ ] break [ __ ]
there's a girl there's juggler girls
yeah yeah they're
fat yeah floppy yep yep [ __ ] with
their titties hanging out and [ __ ] half
nude
totally trashy trashy as [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] clown face painted on them and
it's it's quite you could google it man
google juggalo
gathering what they're doing with the
gathering they film it every year and
you'll be like
they would not be allowed in most
countries
but you know humans are an interesting
species but he's right though the actual
artist and the music
it's a little bit it's quite intelligent
there's a there's a
it's good to it it's good yeah it's got
its own little mythos going
yeah you know they're not trashy as
their fans are
kind of like well they've encouraged
them to be that way yeah but it's about
clowns raps serial killers uh
[ __ ] horror movies everything all
in together like something out of
devil's rejects
but making fun of itself it's funny i
feel like they're not as classy as guar
you know you know what i'm saying no i
don't know much about
i know i know they look like but that's
it they're like like guar
they well yeah there's some similarities
similar
i've seen guaran
yeah i've seen them a bunch of times
that was like that was always a fun show
to go to you had to like wear a [ __ ]
plastic raincoat and [ __ ] so otherwise
you'd have like all kind of fluids all
over you at the end
but yeah so i feel like maybe the bunny
man was uh
the og juggalo maybe
you know i guess if it was 1970 or 1971
yeah so uh apparently so i guess the
comms back in the 70s were looking for
a dude who was in his late teens or
early 20s
dressed like a bunny rabbit um who was
wandering around doing weird [ __ ] like
throwing hatchets to people
now apparently they got like over the
next few weeks
they got like 50 more reports about this
person
um including one report that said that
the bunny man had eaten their
cat which
yeah but was it true i don't know i'm
just saying maybe their cat disappeared
and they just assumed that the bunny man
had eaten it i mean i don't know if they
found
the eaten cat i don't know i'm not real
clear i got hit by a car
oh don't say that but yeah yeah
any time it's like don't talk about a
little kitty's getting hurt
all right talk about people getting hurt
all you want i don't give a [ __ ] about
that but don't talk about cats getting
hurt
so apparently so but the cops couldn't
find this person but like i said this
does seem to have happened because there
were actual police reports about a dude
in a bunny suit throwing
hatchets of people and doing weird [ __ ]
with hatchets so
after a while they couldn't find the
guys so the case like went uh
inactive now they did actually manage to
find the original couple that had seen
the the bunny outside that he had thrown
the hatchet into their car
and um they did confirm it so this isn't
just something where like you know the
paper was like printing an urban legend
or
whatever but apparently he threw the um
the hatchet at the window and i guess it
broke the window because they were
saying that um
when the girl got home like her mom had
to like pick all the glass out of her
hair
so i'm guessing that it broke the window
but like i said it didn't uh hurt
anybody
so i guess from those are like the seeds
of it
and then like i said there were a couple
of other like
sort of unrelated murders that happened
in the area like around the same time
and i feel like people associated
the murders with the dude in the bunny
suit and the hatchet because i mean
that's pretty
alarming like you know being sitting in
a car and seeing and doing a bunny suit
like throwing a [ __ ] axe at you
so i guess they like just assumed that
this guy was a serial killer and like he
had done all this kind of [ __ ]
so i don't know so as the years went on
all these other details were added like
you know now they're gonna hang you from
the bridge and i don't know why that
bridge
specifically maybe just because that
bridge is creepy and it's like in that
area
because i don't know if any of the
sightings of the bunny man were around
that bridge even
but for some reason that bridge got
associated with the bunny man
and now even nowadays like they say if
you go out there on halloween like
you'll get killed by the bunny man and
he's gonna hang you up with all your
guts hanging out
so i don't know but like i said that's
not true but the [ __ ] about the dude in
the bunny suit does appear
to be true so
um what time what time is it okay we're
only in there we're only at work we're
doing
great we're only at one hour
this is a nice light topic it can just
bounce in and out and it's all it's all
good
you want another drink um or you want to
finish it i'll finish this
first chug it chug it chug it no no i'm
just kidding i was actually telling him
to chug it oh yeah
you want you can chug about the same
amount
yeah i mean you know it's pretty it's
still fairly early here it's only six
o'clock
so it's you know like i said if we're
still awake
and alive by 10 o'clock we might pop
over to that
strange realities thing yeah and see
have their little zoom party say hi
and just chill yeah i'm sure you know
everyone's going to be there i guess
because they they didn't do it last
night because i guess last night was the
first night of the couple the chips will
the tip jar still be open
yeah oh i don't know i don't think so
well because like i said i don't know
audience it's just yeah they're not an
audience it's just for it's just for
like the peop the speakers and
all right and the hosts and stuff so
they may want to confer with us
just warn everyone we are drinking well
at the end of our night i think they've
all been drinking too
because it's like the the conference has
been going on all day
was it just yesterday today uh no it's
tomorrow too oh
so it's like a thought yeah because when
when they did it in person it was like
three days it was friday saturday sunday
so they decided to move it all online
this year so they're doing like you know
online [ __ ] like afterward
can we all can we all give you tips to
stay here instead of going there
i mean i think they'd be down well
yeah start seeing them showing in flash
bulbs
all right so now we're going to talk
about
another urban legend that turned out to
be true i think
uh or appears to be true and this one is
from scotland so if anybody's from
scotland they can tell me if they know
this story or not
uh the catman of greenock and i don't
know if i'm pronouncing that right
so this town is um
only about 25 miles west of glasgow
and there was a story that started
circulating
um starting back in the 70s or
thereabouts
so the story goes that there was this
little dude
who was like a man but like more like a
creature
and he was like all black like he had
like
just cold black skin and stuff like that
and he had like his eyes glowed
and he was supposedly like crawl around
in this little town you talk about
flavor flav yeah that's a flavor flavor
spoiler alert
yeah so he would like crawl around like
at night
under the full moon and everything and
he would eat
rodents like rats and mice and stuff and
they would see him and he looked like a
little creature but also kind of like a
man
so apparently this story like went
around for like many many years
of this like guy that was just all black
and he
was just like go around eating rats and
[ __ ] so for a long time
everybody just thought this was like a
scary story like an urban legend
but then um in 2007
uh and i'm not sure like like i said i'm
not sure how
if the story started back in the 70s i
don't really know if this is even the
same
dude that they were talking about but
apparently
like cops had been getting story like
you know reports about him and stuff but
they could never find him but then in
2007 somebody took a video with their
cell phone
and let me see i think i forgot to show
a picture of the bunnyman bridge so
there it is
thank you michael stay here with us
um but yeah where is the uh catman okay
so i didn't really want to do the video
because it was like kind of [ __ ] up
looking but
this is a still from the video uh from
2007
i believe that's what the guy
right there what's his mouth it's a rat
oh god it's a rat
what a weirdo yes so so he's being
oh so i don't so like i said i don't
know
it may be it might be like i don't
really know if
um if the story was like there
at first and then some guy said oh
that's
i'm going to be all i can be i'm going
to turn into the catman of greeneck
which is
and another thing too i don't know why
they call him the catman i mean you
think if anything they would call him
the rat man because he eats rats
maybe because he's hunting rats like a
cat you know oh yeah i guess that's why
i said fetishize i didn't even think of
that
but yeah so so this video surfaces in
2007
and it's this you know it's this guy and
he just looks like he's completely
covered in soot or whatever
and he's crawling around under cars in a
bus garage
and he just has that big rat like
hanging out of his mouth
now as the video goes on he actually
seems to know what the camera is because
he looks at the camera
and like gives it a thumbs up and then
just keeps on eating the rat
in this video so everyone is saying
oh [ __ ] like we thought that catman of
greenneck thing that that was just an
urban legend but now apparently
here he is maybe it wasn't he just
brought to fruition that's maybe that's
what i'm thinking because i think that
story goes back to the 70s
and if somebody didn't get the video
until 2007 it's like was that
was he a kid like in the 70s was he the
kid catman of greenwich be that person
that just finds urban legends that don't
have any reality and you're like i'm
gonna make this really i'm gonna
make this i'm gonna be reality i'm gonna
do this and then
you become part of the one see that's
another thing that bought that's one
thing i'm i'm really fascinated with
urban legends i've read like all of yon
burn vans books and all of that kind of
stuff
one thing that's always kind of bothered
me about urban legends is that
even the ones that are not true and a
lot of them are you know not true but
some of them are like based in something
that was sort of
i would think most of them are so yeah
that they had something
that you know or two things happen at
once and people conflated them or
something like that
um and you know there's some that go
back so far that they're not really even
sure like what the
you know inciting incident was or
whatever and they tend to go
you know urban legends tend to go in
like certain categories
um i always like to like really creepy
ones obviously like you know the
dude under the bed that licks your hand
and all that kind of [ __ ]
but um but i think what
what freaks me out is that sometimes if
an urban legend
like say slenderman for example which is
not exactly an urban legend that's more
like you know creepypasta that kind of
you know became an urban legend i
suppose
but if enough people believe in it like
maybe
even if it wasn't true to start with
then someone will
make it true and that that's what kind
of worries me about like [ __ ] like um
you know like poison halloween candy
right which is kind of a big thing they
don't really talk about as much anymore
because i think that's mostly been
debunked that that is not a thing really
this year it's gonna be like coveted
halloween it is now it's like
everybody's giving you
coconut yeah like with the halloween so
it's like yeah i coughed all over
everything yeah exactly
evolution of the legend yeah that's
going to be the next like 20 years from
now they're going to be talking about
people like putting in their mouth
someone did that and they gave it out to
all the kids in the neighborhood
and then they all got coveted yeah but
yeah so
[ __ ] like that like yes there was one
case where
a little kid died from eating pixy stix
but they turned out it turned out that
his dad or his stepdad
had actually poisoned him like nobody in
the neighborhood had poisoned him he
he went into the kids halloween candy
and put poison in the kids halloween
candy so it was like a family
thing and that's pretty much the only
case where that happened as far as i can
recall
but it always bothers me that the urban
legends that sprung up about people
poisoning
halloween candy or like putting razor
blades in apples which [ __ ] i even heard
that when i was a kid
so i always feel like well the you know
the more prevalent that gets the more
widespread that gets
it's like someone you know someone's
gonna do that like for real
i'm actually surprised that nobody has
done that for real
you know what i mean although i guess
something like that
like with the halloween candy like if
you put razor blades in apple well one
thing if somebody gives you an apple
you're not gonna [ __ ] eat it i mean
everybody knows that right
so and i feel like nowadays people are
so
paranoid about it i mean i think are we
didn't that wasn't that a one-time thing
like that did happen
once yeah maybe like way back in the day
well i don't know about razer or pins
and apples i'm not sure about that
i don't know if there was ever a
documented case of that happening
like i said the only one that i can
think of was the kid that died with from
the pixie stix
but his own dad or his step dad put the
poison in there yeah
it wasn't like a neighborhood kid but
i don't know i don't like i said i'd be
very surprised if some random
sicko somewhere didn't put like a razor
blade yeah i mean
it sounds like something someone would
do once but
yeah it's not an epidemic or hypodermic
needles wasn't that a thing
oh yeah yeah yeah that was another thing
where people were like
and another thing too um i remember
i don't think this was super widespread
but i think there was an urban legend
that went around
that if you were in a movie theater like
that
sex traffickers would come up and like
uh put you know [ __ ] uh they would
put a hypodermic needle like in your
butt like through the crack in the seat
like to knock you out and then like drag
where was this where
i don't have this it's like it wasn't it
is it's an urban legend i don't think
that ever really happened
i'm not saying that people don't get
kidnapped so like little kids get
kidnapped they do
yes they do but in that specific way i
don't think i've ever heard of that
specific way
happening like specifically like the so
it sounds like something
somebody was afraid that it would happen
to them so then they made up the legend
or you'd tell your kids that because
that's how it always was when i was
little like my mom would always like
make [ __ ] up no no no no like they heard
something like the halloween candy thing
like your parent would tell you that to
scare you or to like make you be safe
like don't you dare do this because this
is gonna happen
yeah you know and they heard it from
somewhere else and that's how it
probably was with the you're gonna get
kidnapped or like you know don't talk to
strangers because this is gonna happen
or that you're gonna
you're gonna sit on a hypodermic needle
they're gonna drag you yeah someone's
gonna stick a hypodermic here when
you're sitting in the movie theater it's
like you know what i mean
and like i said it's you know it's
understandable because yes you want to
protect your kids yes you want
you know and there are like a lot of
people that do [ __ ] up things like i
write about that [ __ ] all the time so
horrible [ __ ] up [ __ ] does happen it's
just that
one i don't think it's as widespread as
everyone thinks it is somebody's talking
about putting pins and strawberries in
australia
we had a thing here about putting razor
blades in that's what we were talking
about yeah but you know what
um the the the poison halloween candy
only happened once that's that's not
there's one
yeah and it was a and it was a father
who poisoned his own children
yeah it's i already said i was out i
didn't
it never happened yeah i don't you know
and
if you put a razor blade in an apple and
hand it out to kids
and that kid [ __ ] bit into that apple
they would immediately remember
what street and what house that came
from they'd find well yeah because
you're like after that one first yeah
you're that one person
they would know exactly what the people
would remember because you would have
given out a lot of apples probably
yeah and you know they would all know
they would remember where they got just
like on my street we always remembered
the loser who would just give you five
pennies
did anyone else have live near dentists
because i had at least one or two
dentists that would give out
toothbrushes
that yeah and i was kind of okay with
that i was like oh free toothpaste
all right well yeah it's like that
wasn't really that's a little different
and fun
like you know okay no candy just just a
toothbrush
well he's a dentist not sure they might
have done both but you know those
dentists they get the ones with their
name on they probably have so many
like handed out your card yeah kind of
but i mean it's different you know i
don't know
it didn't really bother me it got enough
candy yep but yeah the old guy that gave
us pennies now i have heard an urban
legend too about some old dudes that
would like put the pennies on a skillet
and then like give them to you but it's
like why would anybody go to that much
trouble and then it would cool off
pretty quickly that's what i mean it's
like by the time that yeah what are you
gonna do you're gonna cook it right
there by the door and just be like hey
here you go kid i don't know about you
i'll be like well i gotta hand out that
candy i get sick of it they keep reading
the damn door
[ __ ] to the kids then i go back down
there and get although i give out candy
i give out candy i try to run out of
candy well yeah
you better come to my house i'll give
you i'll give you here you want five
okay yeah here
just take what you want
well i feel like kids start like they
they trick or treat earlier because most
of the kids around here are like are
little
so they usually trick-or-treat pretty
early so like it's by the time it gets
dark
you don't you're we're not going to get
them anymore so it's like the last few
that you get you're just like dumping
[ __ ] in there it's like look we don't
want to keep it we're just going to eat
it and get fat i don't want it all
anymore
but yeah so 2007 this video surfaces
of this dude who looks every bit like
the urban legend of the cat man of
greeneck you need to show tom that
he's even eaten the rat and everything
he doesn't even eat in the rat and
everything yeah like i said i don't know
if it's your back up
yeah there he is look at he's got a rat
in his mouth he's got some kind of you
have masks
let me look at my let me look here he's
trying to be a cat
like a cat with a rat like this that's a
staged photo
yeah i kind of feel like
and uh that's that's some [ __ ] from
europe
there's a definite european she said
it's scottish right it does yeah
there you go well on the other side on
the british island he's just trying to
said he's trying to make this legend
come to fruition yeah yeah you know why
i'm telling you that's europa
or uk you know how i called that that
[ __ ] color look at that color
that teal color yeah yeah no
self-respecting american would be caught
next to anything colored teal like that
we don't have a steel in the united
states
that's it i thought that was
institutional colors you know what i
mean like well
we don't want to look like a military
base so let's paint painted blue what's
the cheapest color blue we can get well
there's like this shitty teal
yeah yeah that's blue all right now
paint this one green what's the cheapest
[ __ ] we can get per gal
well i got this mint [ __ ] green [ __ ]
yeah yeah we did that right there wants
easter colors
easter colors it's festive yeah i
remember when i was a kid
kanavatsan's on there man he can he can
he can he can
he can answer whenever you saw a picture
of tj
tijuana that's where that's where khan
lives it was all in those [ __ ] easter
colors
the little houses back in the day
they're probably not now
but back in the 70s they were all in
those
kind of like easter egg colors that was
like real popular for
mexican houses yeah i don't think
lavender
and pink yeah lavender and pink
trim on a on a on a teal house
or like a mint green house with
like like a lavender trim on it
if he's still with the choice he's still
listening you know he
he could chime in but that's the way i
remembered it
yeah that's why i remembered as a kid
living in california
you know that's where tijuana looked i
don't know if it looks that way anymore
but
probably not alex was just saying that
one halloween he heard about a guy that
was handing out individual
unwrapped almonds yeah i feel like that
was probably the guy that was like oh
[ __ ] it's halloween and he forgot to buy
candy what have i got
what if i got to make a statement like
just to to be the person you talk about
online
look at that to me that guy yeah you're
that guy why do you want to be that guy
nobody wants to be
one year i made my mom was like again no
one's gonna eat them i wanted to make
mini cupcakes and i was like how cool
would it
be to give like the parents like you
want a mini cupcake or ever so i made
like
a hundred mini cupcakes yeah and it was
a good old michigan halloween so it was
like 30 degrees
and sleeting and i didn't even bring
them outside
and my mom was like no one's gonna eat
them because they're gonna think they're
poison and i'm like but i just wanted to
do something different for people
but no i think we ended up just eating
them over the next few weeks
yeah because most people will not take
um yeah
anything homemade oh alex said i didn't
hear about it he handed them to me
oh that's crazy that's crazy
but yeah like i get it you want to be
different on halloween i you know like
you want to stand out
and you're just trying to do something
fun but people are
people have all these superstitious like
oh they're gonna poison me they're gonna
kill me
well and plus it's like you don't want
to be the one it's like when we went
trick-or-treating and what we used to do
because i was kind of poor when we was a
kid so we would like always drive to
like the
more the upper middle class neighborhood
you might come to my neighborhood
because you get
to get the kids from like poor
neighborhoods
we just live in it like a regular ass
you know there's houses and it's safe so
we get kids
all over the place yeah so we would go
there because they have better candy
than like because you know
like our neighborhood you just kind of
got that [ __ ] that big bag of like
lame ass like [ __ ] dum-dum lollipops
and all that kind of stuff that you got
for like
two bucks or something and it's like you
get that kind of stuff and you're like
you wanted like little fun size snickers
man
kit kats [ __ ] like that yeah my parents
neighborhood it's not rich but they
there's so many people and because we
get so many kids more people participate
so your chances of getting like a full
bag are higher
so we get the poor kids and stuff to
come on over and we like it we're like
yeah come on over
i remember the ones i used to get all
kinds of these things called sweeties
yeah yeah yeah everybody that long has a
long roll it sounds like smarties are
you doing
smarties okay smarties are gross
yeah we used to get them both sweet
tarts bottle caps and smarties i only
like sweethearts out of all three and
then uh
bottle caps only the root beer ones are
good the rest of them
yeah yeah yeah i think so they were they
were little hard candies and in the
center they had a white powder
yeah yeah yeah get those
uh pixie stix the paper pips yes
yeah yeah yeah i like those yeah that's
because you could get a big bag of that
[ __ ] for real cheap that's at least get
out in california
yeah then you know move into the [ __ ]
higher end
uh neighborhoods they're gonna give you
snickers and three yeah he's gonna get
like chocolate get that chocolate candy
yeah you're not gonna get like i said
you're not gonna get this [ __ ]
you're not gonna get those [ __ ]
lollipops like the free ones they give
you at the bank
tootsie rolls were the
like if that's worst that's all you gave
out was i ate them though you know
i like that i like the tootsie rolls the
the vanilla ones
okay the vanilla ones are good yeah
vanilla and strawberry i don't even know
if those are
technically tootsie rolls yeah is that
another brand no stitching
what are they making those who are they
making them for somebody because they
still sell
this neighborhood here is a bonanza the
kids
in here man they [ __ ] hit i look i
look in their bags when i'm throwing
bags
i'm going this [ __ ] are handing
out good candy it's like maybe we should
go trick-or-treating
i went one time with a friend that lived
in a rich neighborhood
i went one time with her when i was in
like middle school or something and we
got some like full-size
like hershey bars and stuff i was like
oh [ __ ]
you guys don't mess around they bring
nick
they bring that but the worst part is is
those houses are bigger and more spaced
apart so if you go to a really rich
neighborhood you gotta do run in
you gotta run and you like you get maybe
less but you get
bigger so it's like which which is plus
you get some exercise
yeah do you want less houses but bigger
or do you want to go to more houses and
just get more of it you know
so yeah see that's the thing i feel like
quality not quantity
yeah you know that's most of the
trick-or-treaters in this neighborhood
they come from this neighborhood
and we have well yeah because this is a
big right we have we had
i don't know if they're still around i
haven't seen them i haven't seen them in
the numbers
uh uh from four or five years ago we had
all those
[ __ ] tech families the in from india
yeah yeah they were they were indian
kids from these high-tech families
working in the tech industry those kids
[ __ ] knew the deal
they would walk up and look in that damn
bowl and go uh
i'm
i think i'll i think i'll take the
reese's peanut butter cups
yeah they're like that yeah once i saw
him do that because man these kids these
kids are too gourmet and [ __ ] around
here
[ __ ] happened i started handing it out
don't let them choose just because well
that's the whole they know too much
you're supposed to we never like
picked you just take it and then when
you get home if you have siblings you
lay down you trade and you trade you
trust yeah somebody said that earlier
don't mess around when he didn't he
doesn't have any siblings yeah you
wouldn't know how this works
but no you just take whatever and then
you get home and you trade or
whatever yeah that's how you do it no
it's like those indian kids live here
man they're they're their parents
schooled down well they
they only like the good yes let me see
what do we have
where's the pharaoh rochet yeah yeah oh
i would be all over that yeah somebody
gave out some ferrero rocher
yeah i love that [ __ ] yeah these [ __ ]
getting too spoiled around here
take their [ __ ] three musketeer hit
the road kid
oh not the three musketeer oh no not the
three of us
those are all right yeah i'll eat them
if there's nothing else they're better
when they're frozen
they are snickers are also better when
they're frozen
well snickers is good you know that way
but actually i don't know if they still
make it but they i was showing three
musketeers to these kids and they were
like uh
uh i get that i get that they probably
know about that
no they knew what it was they knew
exactly what that [ __ ] was they were
raised here okay
i mean like i said i'll eat a three
musketeers if someone says hey one of
three musketeers it's free
i'll be like yeah okay but it's not what
i would pick usually
because it's not there's nothing in it
you know what i mean i if i'm gonna have
a chocolate bar i want some substance
man i want some [ __ ] nuts in there
i definitely want some nuts in there
that's all i'm saying but yeah so
he's got to leave he's in trouble his
wife's saying he can't listen to the
stream anymore
oh no he does some [ __ ] why no he just
just
he never didn't answer me about the damn
easter egg colored houses i remembered
that part he wasn't around yeah maybe
not yeah
well the little butterfingers are good i
don't know i just ate his hat i actually
like the little fun size butterfingers
better than the full-size ones because
the thing about
butter is that you have to get
them when they're fresh and they don't
stay fresh very long
the one i liked man i liked it ever
since it came out when i was a little
kid back in the 70s was toffee fae
remember those things
they still sell those they still sell we
bought some the other day it's a little
rack
it's good with like five little drops in
it and it was a little
thing a it was a toffee [ __ ] cup
filled with nougat
chocolate and an almond or a hair i've
never had anything
they were really good yes i would say
pre vegan i used to love whoppers which
was like the malt balls i was all over
those
nerds which i still like they're vegan
they're like that sour
little pieces those are good and then
yeah like heath bars and stuff if anyone
gave out those
i'm all over yeah heather i used to be
yeah and i like um
mr goodbar as well i don't think i like
that because i had the like
thing where i was a kid and nobody liked
nuts i don't know if anyone had that
where like kids don't like nuts
that's so weird i love i loved
yeah you talk about mary janes i
remember those two that chew yeah yeah
yeah i love them things
you got to heat them up a little bit
they won't pull your teeth out just kind
of warm them up just a little bit
they're kind of like do you remember
chocolate recent do they still make
those yes that's like a european thing
those are like they're really good too
but yeah they'll really like whatever
they'll pull all your fillings what i
like is that damn
scandinavian licorice that scandinavian
black licorice man
do you know that i was just reading an
article today
about if you eat too much licorice
because they were talking about this one
guy that like ate two bags of it a day
or something like that black licorice
yeah um that'll like [ __ ] your heart up
i don't doubt because like all the stuff
that's in
in there in there like that particular
licorice
flavoring will like give you heart
arrhythmia and stuff like that
i don't know what it is maybe it's a
white people thing but [ __ ] there's
something about black licorice
i just [ __ ] love it well it's not i'm
white and i hate that [ __ ]
i don't know i don't even really i've
never seen a person who wasn't white be
able to eat it
because it's terrible i [ __ ] love it
maybe it's something
it's a thing i think it's something
genetic that something it's very
divisive
black licorice it's funny i was just
reading the article but i'm not talking
about the fake black licorice the real
one it's almost like eating a piece of
beef jerky
it's [ __ ] it has it it's savory yeah
more than candy
salty and [ __ ] kind of spicy and real
rich flavor
it's nothing like like a you know like a
black gumball
or a black actually a black juji fruit
or it's nothing like that
it's it's like eating a piece of down
beef or something
beef jerky is what it reminds me of and
yeah and it's kind of
spicy i just like it and i've only other
people i've seen that like it
are the occasional white person i've
never seen a black person eating it i
mean maybe
i tell you what the scandinavians love
that [ __ ] i [ __ ] love it they love
that [ __ ]
and they they even have like i i read
that they even have like um
like liqueurs and stuff like drinks that
they mix with that flavor
and it's like i've heard of people that
could like from over here that went over
there and drank it and were just like oh
my god it's the worst thing ever
they love it every time i had you know
you [ __ ] black dudes in the army or
whatever they're like i don't want you
know
no no yeah you can have all of it you
can have all that you don't want that no
no no no no i feel like
the majority of people don't need it but
it's not good i don't like it i love it
i think like i said i think it might be
something slightly genetic
in the way that you know like some
people some people genetically they
can't
eat mango i think it is cilantro
cilantro it tastes like so
to them it tastes like soap and to other
people it doesn't it depends on your
jeans
although i have a thing where like i
love cilantro but i have a thing where
mango to me tastes like perfume yeah
and i don't know yeah it's like i can
eat it but it tastes like
drinking a bottle of perfume but i can't
we are but i can have like i can have
like
like i've had mango ice cream like at
the indian restaurant
and that's good but i can't like a
regular just
eating a mango because my ex-husband
loved those so he used to buy them all
the time
and i would eat a piece and i'd be like
why are you drinking it tastes like
[ __ ]
you know charlie or whatever that
[ __ ] old tammy says
from the 70s i don't know which yeah
you're not
because i'm trying to make it sound
better and turns like it's like it
tastes like beef jerky
it's savory it's it's salty
and spicy and and there's no other way
to describe it it's just
go get you some real beef jerky so i'm
not beatrix
black licorice like something from
scandinavia like some [ __ ] stuff i've
had all different kind
like it's not like i haven't tried i
just i just don't like it it's just not
good
i'm just not one of the and i'll eat you
know me it's like i'm not
within reason i'll eat pretty much
anything but
you know there's some things i'm just
like there's something about it i
[ __ ] just like how it is
and like i said we've you know we've
talked about this where you know candy
if i'm gonna eat candy and i'm gonna
like commit to like eating those
calories i want some [ __ ] good
i want some chocolate in there i want
some [ __ ] nuts in there i want some
nougat i want caramel i want all the
[ __ ]
louie says he's mexican he can eat
anything and i attest to that fact
you're lucky mexicans can eat anything
but mexicans
also have a good sense of flavor all
right real mexican food
homemade tortillas but can all those
street tacos and everything that they're
making you know [ __ ] tacos
el pastor and all that mexicans know
food
they're foodies they're [ __ ] serious
about that [ __ ] we need to finish
watching that taco documentary we
watched the first couple episodes and
they were really good
yeah i mean it was making me inspired a
lot
i get inspired a lot by watching that
mexican mexican street food
stuff i love food shows they're putting
the damn gravy on
gravy on the on the [ __ ] tacos yeah
it's the stew
and then yeah stew type tacos and then
they i can't remember the word they cook
the taco see i make my own tortilla
shells and you make the you make your
corn tortilla and you cook it
in oil that has
been [ __ ] with the chorizo so it's
kind of reddish
you know it's been [ __ ] weird it's
[ __ ] with the cherry the chorizo has
been [ __ ] with that oil
the oil that comes out you know you see
when oil
love each other very much you know
bacony kind of flavor to it you know
it's it's salty
it's good you know mexicans put chili on
stuff
putting chili on cactus and [ __ ] and
eating it
yeah you know cooked cactus every single
the first two episodes
of that taco show that we watched every
single thing on there i was like yep
i want that in my mouth right now i can
eat side by side with mexicans you know
i eat that [ __ ] mexican [ __ ] hot
sauce that is just so [ __ ] hot you
know the habanero sauce is [ __ ] brown
yeah burn you up i [ __ ] love that
[ __ ] he loves that mayan like
hot super hot super hot [ __ ] it's like
team no spice
no no or very mild spice over here
i like i like spicy but only up to a
point and and i actually like a little
bit more spice but
as the older i get like the less i can
eat it because it i'll be
hating life later on see hernandez knows
what's up tom doesn't know what's up tom
wants to i love i love all food i love
food from around the world
there is some [ __ ] that i don't like
michael asked me if i would eat scrapple
i haven't eaten it
my grandpa loved it um i was not a fan
yeah
in my experience you know growing up in
brazil and [ __ ] having central
central and south oh the food from the
americas
north central and south america really
is the best food
it is even though there's some middle
eastern food that's [ __ ] dynamite
there's european stuff that's pretty
good it's not spicy enough for me but
still
certain things it's some of it's pretty
good
but man when you talk about american
food what makes american food [ __ ]
bad
ass it is a mexican influence on it
yeah an italian influence on it yeah and
then there's a little bit of
influence from india and a little bit of
influence from american indians
but mexican food has influenced american
palettes a lot
i mean holy [ __ ] nowadays i mean oh
thank you ken
thanks thank you ken nowadays
trying to interrupt yes so wrapping
paper she's detecting she
i said we're talking about mexican food
chorizo juice is a base for the chili
con carne yeah
girl you're making a bunch of stuff
spanish chorizo is also good
i have spanish chorizo here right now
goya i got some agoya chorizo it's
pretty good it's not
the same spice profile as mexican
chorizo but you just
you get it when you can find it but they
got a real good mexican store
about 10 miles from here that i used to
have to run up there all the time to get
[ __ ] hot sauce
yeah but they have [ __ ] homemade
stuff there that you can get it's really
good yeah he rides up on there as well
right yeah use this that's where all the
mexican workers are shopping yeah
yeah you know what i mean you go in
there i'm like the only way to win there
you know what i mean it's kind of like
when we go to the indian market like
when we go to house of spices and we're
the only
people with only white people in the
store yeah right and they're all and
they're all like super into like what
are you hearing
what are you making yeah they're all
like interested in what we're making
like the women
back there last time pakistani woman i'm
walking by she goes hey hey
what are you making and i started i
started laughing it says i'm in this
store and you're asking me what
i'm cooking and she's like yeah it was a
white boy yeah yeah yeah
he's making butter chicken she goes oh
and i said yes not pakistani
and i said but this is a pakistani
company she goes yeah that's the best
one that's the best one maybe she could
give you some
some recipes i don't know we have we
haven't there's a woman named nikki that
works there
she's super awesome and uh she's told us
like a few
she's given us some cooking tips and
stuff like that because i mean
if i had to i don't know if i could if i
had to pick like one
region of the world like their cuisine
like as my favorite it'd probably be
indian food
sophie chad is trying to pick you up
he's talking about music and if you talk
about music
i'm all ears
yeah i'm here for that
all right so what was that okay i'll
keep it down
before you start talking again okay so
it's my birthday i'm just like i'm not
even
of course it's only a quarter to seven
here so i don't want it we've got two
through three or two and a half um this
is the third oh we still
know the cat the cat man yeah okay we
gotta finish the cat man yeah see this
one okay
so this one like i said yes it's a
legend and yes like people started
videotaping or taking pictures of this
dude
and it wasn't just this one video it was
like you know subsequently like other
people started going around taking
pictures of him
so as more pictures of him started
you know surfacing online then the
authorities kind of started to get word
because they're like well obviously that
maybe this dude has some mental problems
and maybe we should like you know find
him and like you know help him and like
put him someplace so
they so basically i don't know if they
could ever find the dude it's like he it
seemed like he was real elusive
like he lived in a junkyard or something
like that but he was always kind of like
and apparently he ate
rats and stuff i don't really know but
the story behind and i don't know if
this is true or not but the story behind
the catman is that apparently
he was a russian sailor and somehow he
got stranded in scotland i don't know
how because
i had to get stranded in scotland in
this day and age i don't really know
but see so he got stranded there and
then he went crazy
um he got stranded there in the 1970s
and then he went crazy and then he
started thank you and then he started
living on the streets
and you know his mental state
deteriorated and then he started
um you know basically just going around
like living off the land
and like eating rats and [ __ ] like that
um what was that i don't know
it sounded like something didn't it well
no it sounded like something
see it sounded like something hit in the
house not that loud though
it wasn't that long because we do have
some [ __ ] like
[ __ ] falls on the roof yeah that's what
it sounds like like from trees
or i don't know if it's squirrels i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is every now
and then like something and uh plus we
have like the sanford airport is really
close to here and i know what it is
we're writing the flight pattern
out it probably is honestly yeah she
probably went up the
okay yeah she was in the cat tree one of
these days
she is gonna knock that over yeah
because
what she'll do is i mean she's still
pretty small but she's what like 10 11
pounds
yeah she'll run up there she runs across
the whole entire house and then
jumps up on it and she's like and it
starts right and it's like she's
swinging on it and she's like what she's
swinging on it
yeah one of these days that thing is
gonna [ __ ] crash to the ground
and i don't want to be here for this
because like i keep telling her like
pokey
calm down but yeah so they don't know if
this guy like actually
what kind of ass i'm saying he's a mandy
line he does whatever his woman wants
him to do i was laughing at that
he's laughing he's [ __ ] funny wow
you need to you need to talk to that guy
i talked to him every day a man who does
whatever your woman wants to know
i like that yeah they call that being
[ __ ] whipped up here bro
yeah a little bit i like that idea
though
there's something wrong with man nothing
wrong with the vagina is he not
no he he he's five year good dude he's a
good he's a good family man you know he
just needs to get his
photographs a little his family photos
he needs to do him a little more retro
he had him he's sitting there like he's
in the damn satan chair and [ __ ] with
his brood next to him
but what he should have done is put her
in the spanish vail
and had him there with the damn lever
action [ __ ] rifle from the 1800s
and had the kid dressed kids dressed up
like something off of the adams family
you know what i mean you'd have [ __ ]
i mean that'd be cool should take it
back to the late 1800s like
it would have been even in it and he had
to have a top hat on
and it would have been even more [ __ ]
mexican it would have been mexican as
hell
it looked like something out of dia de
los muertos your christmas pictures
that's what you should
yeah yeah you can send that out to
everybody that's your christmas card
yeah matter of fact the tequila that i'm
drinking right now is a day of the dead
tequila special that came out and it's
[ __ ] good man
i showed it to him you
yeah i'm really into it like you know
because i'm a graphic designer i'm
really into like liquor bottle design
yeah he says it's a good idea he'll call
it
al mormon style stuff
don't understand better than the mormons
a lot of the mormons are in mexico as
something a lot of people don't
understand well they snuck down there
they went down there yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah well they've been in there for over
100 years i know
yeah but they got a good relationship
every day with the mexican government i
think the mexican government uses them
for stuff
goes away from yeah use them for
security
we i was thinking about mormons and then
i was thinking about vivarium because we
just watched bavaria
and i was just like they all look like
mormons what the [ __ ] was that a
statement
we've seen it three times now it just
keeps getting better it's a good thing
i saw it for the first time and i have
to say like i looked it
looked it up online and it has a pretty
low rating on like imdb and i don't
think it deserves that
yeah i don't get that pretty good they
didn't know what they were looking at
it's well it's weird and weird movies
are awesome weird but it doesn't make it
bad
it's not bad at all i like weird it's a
different kind of sci-fi [ __ ]
yeah but it's no different than like you
know it makes you think it's good acting
i don't see what's bad about that it's
not bad
yeah it's a very unique sci-fi horror
movie
it's weird because like as soon as it
came on like as soon as i got
the vibe of it like as soon as they
drove into that neighborhood i'm like oh
i'm all in
i mean the movie is very welcoming i
just loved the whole tone of it and i
really liked like the whole
it's a it's an irish movie in it yeah
the director's it's an irish movie yeah
yeah it's real good it's real good
but yeah so speaking of well i was going
to say speaking of ireland but now
speaking of scotland it's completely
different country
but yeah so so the story about this guy
we don't know if he was a russian
soldier who got stranded back in
scotland in the 70s and then like
started living on the street and then
like went crazy and then started eating
rats or whatever
or um some other legends about him say
that i don't know if he's still russian
in this scenario but
that he got in trouble with the mob and
they broke his legs
so and then like i guess they didn't
heal properly so now he has to crawl
around
because nobody's ever seen him walking
he's always crawling like an
animal like underneath stuff and like i
said
yes this video that came out in 2007 you
know that could have been faked but
subsequently like other videos and other
photos of him have come out
and so apparently some people are
keeping tabs but i guess the authorities
can never really find him when they go
to look for him because like i said
they're trying to
you know see if he needs any help
because he obviously
seems like he might need some um so
apparently some people have spoken to
him i don't think he can talk
um or he doesn't seem to but
they the people that have talked to him
said he seems kind of weird but he's not
like
scary or dangerous or anything like he
seems pretty harmless
um they said he probably lives out in
the woods because they usually see him
coming out of like
the woods or you know the scrub or
whatever um he can
kind of stand up but he can't really you
know he kind of like responds to people
but he doesn't seem to be able to speak
um or he can't speak english at any rate
um
he just kind of like makes hand gestures
at people like
telling them like he can do thumbs up
and things but that's about it
um like i said he's usually crawling
around on the ground uh he eats
uh mice and he eats rats sometimes
people leave him food
and he'll eat it so there's that
um and like i said i'm not sure if they
call him catman because he eats rats
or some people have speculated maybe he
takes care of stray cats
like maybe he lives in a den with some
cats that he takes care of
no one's real sure about building a
mythology they maybe are now this guy
does have
uh a facebook fan page if you want to go
check that out like people that like
uh live in that area and like are out
looking for them and like take pictures
and stuff there is like pictures of them
and everything
so whether this guy is the actual
like i said the guy in that video
doesn't look old enough
to be the dude from the urban legend
because the urban legend goes back to
the 70s
at least and if the
if this was the same guy he would have
had to have been a kid back then
right because that was a long time ago
so
i don't so i don't know if this is just
like another iterator for there's more
than one or if this is a guy that
decided he was gonna be the cat man and
now he's doing it
yeah so this is maybe another case like
we were talking about before
of an urban legend which wasn't true but
then somebody decided they were gonna
make it true
you're right you know what i mean like
they killed like somebody uh
trying to revive spring hill jim jack
yeah
that's right i'm drinking jim jack he
says jim because that was a morrissey
song
yeah yeah that's right yeah
but i had to every when we did a show on
spring hill jack i had to remind him
every single
day so you know what you should who'd
you say more spring hill jim yeah
you should be mad at morrissey for
[ __ ] it up why don't you
why not just call it spring hill jack
like the real thing why because he's
talking about a dude named jim that he
knows
right he's comparing him yes but then he
did that he messed it up
for everybody he got two of them in here
not bullying me
dude they're like cry boys i just said i
said bloom mercy not you
it's gonna be all right it's not your
fault he wrote the song
to confuse you i told tom earlier today
that only he's the only ones allowed to
pick on people
people when people pick on him he gets
all that oh no i take it off of them
just making a show tammy said in the in
the card that we only bust your balls
because we love you
i know that yeah leave tom alone guys
says you guys gotta understand so i
i went ahead i went ahead and told this
story cookie still loves you tom says
i already went and told this story
sometimes i start drinking i get beta
and then the girls start [ __ ] picking
on me and then the bartender has to save
me
and then i have to go home early
you are the bartender
tiffany jumps in are you okay thomas she
picking on you yes he's picking on me
she's picking up me
it's hurting my little feelings
and i start baiting and out and she's
going yeah yeah so funny
i love it it's my birthday i can be an
[ __ ] today if i want to be no it's
your party and you can cry if you want
to yeah
and also or be an [ __ ] i could be an
[ __ ] if i want to
i haven't been an [ __ ] today no tom
going home early is effeminate says alex
yeah it says feminine
yeah so catman if anybody is from
scotland uh as
far as i know i don't know if there are
any reason i didn't check the facebook
page today
but uh apparently there have been
pictures of this guy surfacing as
recently as 2015 or 2017 rather
summer of 2017. you're telling me to dig
up
big up yeah yeah give my hand my [ __ ]
and androgen levels up look at spock is
like
looking at you he's looking at you with
his little muscles he's like i'm just
i'm just not having it i'm not having it
he's supposed to be the strength of five
men though five times that's why he's a
vulcan
yeah he doesn't need you he doesn't need
muscles he can just kick your ass
he has muscle in that in that picture
yeah this is shirt though
he doesn't have anything so foxy i love
that [ __ ] i love it that's why i got it
for you i feel like it's cooling off in
here though
maybe maybe your hot flash past yeah
your monopod see look at that [ __ ] man
see they're talking about my my hormone
levels you're the one complaining
about my heart he starts it and then
i think it's 71 in here now i have hot
flashes
i'm getting to that age
not right now some exogenous some
exogenous estrogen
i don't know if i want that or not
estrogen injections
where are you going don't see what
temperature it is oh okay he has to go
check the thermos
he has to prove himself right or wrong
he's going to say is it 71 in here well
see that's
i think we got into this on the show one
time too when i was really drunk because
this is something
this is something that really really
bothers me like just as a as a female
injury i know where you're going with
that yeah
is that it's it's cotton here and you're
like well that's subjective
right and so that's what i mean and it's
like he'll like i'll go in the
i'll go in the room to get a sweater
because it's like really cold in my
office for example
why are you gonna sweat it it's not cold
or hot or it's not cold yeah and i'm
like
i'm cold that's why i'm getting a
sweater it's like why
it's actually 70 degrees it's getting
cool in here we'll see there you go
see there there there's that's that's
what i got in there yeah see fancy
see dated it's exotic exotic
zaneta says guys have an obsession with
thermostats they do
what is that about because our
metabolisms run harder they run harder
and we're okay
we get hot no but you're always checking
them my dad's like that too but you know
he's gotta check it yeah
we're touching the thermostat i'm
worried my dad used to say that
it didn't break the air conditioner did
not break this summer
so i'm paranoid it usually breaks every
[ __ ] summer
summer's not over yeah actually it is it
hurts you
it i think i did last week but it did
but like it's florida
so i feel like florida it's kind of like
summer summer
summer oh look a cold day oh it's summer
again
it's kind of like that it's kind of
sucky
i know that people that live in cold
climates are always complaining and
they're just like oh you live in florida
it's like warm all the time but it gets
old you know
i'm just gonna say i wish i lived where
it was warm all the time because
i don't like it i'm a reptile and i'm
like cold
are they cold-blooded yeah cold i think
about that for a second cold-blooded
because they like it warm
yeah it's gotta leave oh
have a good one bro don't get in trouble
on our account
video yep later you can just finish it
fourth drawer down said the reason you
guys are like so obsessed with
thermostats is because we're paying for
the damn gas
not always no because like we it's ours
is electric and plus
we we split it so yeah we just but you
know and
i got that [ __ ] [ __ ] set up to where
we play a yearly average
so our bill is the same every month
every month because otherwise it would
be like super cheap in the winter
and then it would be like five times
more in the summer so we have it so it's
all evened out
which i would like that i would
recommend yeah here in florida yeah
because you gotta run
all year long we don't have that [ __ ] no
we don't run it all year we have a
window air conditioner and it only
cools one room so where i spend most of
my time there's no air conditioning so
it's just that you have to run the ac
like like for eight months out of the
year and then
in the winter you very rarely have to
run the heat
yeah i mean very rarely rarely and like
even when it's like really cold and
we're like oh we'll turn the heat on
after like 10 minutes i'm like turn that
[ __ ] off i can't stand it i can't stand
your nostrils out and [ __ ] i can't even
stand having i can't even stand having
the heat on in the car
yeah even when it's freezing outside
well like i can't stand having hot
whatever that heat is
not it's not good for you though it's
very dry heat yes yeah i don't like it
it'll dry your skin out
yeah your nose will run or it'll bleed
and stuff like that you don't want to
bleed yeah yeah it might yeah my lips
start to crack i mean they do that
anyway but like that makes it
normally won't get below 60 in the house
though
no it won't usually drop and like i said
even if it's cold in the house
like you just put a sweater on i'll just
put a sweater on or an extra blanket i'm
not like putting the [ __ ] heat on
unless i love it unless it's really i
mean it really really has to be cold
before i turn the heat on
even in the car the cats love it when
it's 60. they do
it's like whoa we're free they're
running around
yeah they get all excited yeah well
because they're the same as we are like
in the summer time
like we'll let them run out of the porch
he'll open the door they'll go
[ __ ] that and then they'll turn around
and come back just like they're in the
oven and they're like oh
yeah it's like no no thank you i changed
my mind i could easily live down here
i'm like one of those little lizards
that runs around
like i don't like it every time you come
down here you you're protected inside
this house
no because you stepped up as it's like
[ __ ] a raccoon i know but
i should have brought i didn't i was
like now i don't need to bring a fuzzy
hood i needed to bring a fuzzy freaking
hoodie down here because you guys keep
it so cold
it's only 71 degrees in here sometimes
i'm cold in the house sometimes i'm hot
in the house
i'm tempted to just go walk out the door
and get like we got a show to do you
guys are talking about the ac
that's okay i told you we're like we're
basically three and we're doing good
okay we're doing it
we got like we only got like two more
cases okay yeah and we're only like at
two hours and 12 minutes we're doing
great
it's totally fine perfectly danny says
humidity is the worst it is
no humidity is good for your skin i'm
gonna fight that one
yeah i know i don't i don't like dry
skin either like i said i have to put i
have to put [ __ ] on my lips like all the
time like vaseline or like
you know whatever or my lips will crack
but i really really don't like being
sticky 24 7. oracle saying tom this is
the show it is the show
that's what i mean so it's like we know
that we know that
yeah you know we got people that come
and go
that maybe they don't even subscribe i
don't know you know we get you about 2
000 hits or 1500 hits on a big show
most of them aren't paying us the people
that pay us are the ones that
think that this is the show and that's
the [ __ ] funny part of it
so you notice that jenny we'll see so
that's what i figured like people that
are on patreon or people that like give
us money on here and stuff like that i'm
like well let's just like hang out with
those people like you know that's you
know what i mean
it's like you guys you guys have been
with us for like forever
yeah like i'm not really worried about
like some brando coming across the show
yeah i've seen some [ __ ] rando
comments you know
boy this show would be great if they
could stick to the [ __ ] [ __ ] you're not
paying us
go somewhere else yeah or if we can stop
swearing and i'm like yeah i'm sorry
it's not gonna happen that's not gonna
happen
you're not you don't you know that's not
gonna happen you're not paying us
the people that are paying us are the
ones i can't i'm like gordon
i'm like gordon ramsay if i had to stop
swearing i would just never talk
i know i can't talk without swearing
yeah i mean
it's not normal for us i can shut it i'm
actually pretty good about
knowing my audience you know if i'm with
like my grandma or someone like that or
kids i'm pretty good at shutting off
but i'm not it's not i've been like
i've gotten in trouble like a bunch of
times like especially around like
friends kids and stuff because i'll just
be like talking like random and i'm just
like
blah [ __ ] this and that and then just
like oh yes sorry kid don't repeat that
if you look at what's popular on you on
youtube and that that
generates income and shows that actually
grow it's [ __ ] ludicrous it's
ridiculous
this show it it's channels like copper
cab and copper cab just gets on there
and clowns through the whole [ __ ]
thing it doesn't make any goddamn sense
and he does very well i wouldn't pay
that [ __ ]
cop it would come that's it but i
wouldn't pay it they got that
he's got fans all these guys yeah
well you know he's got it i can't watch
stuff like that maybe it's because i'm
old i don't know
it's i think it's kids mostly but it
it's it's that brand of humor it's a
comedy show
yeah man that's that's what they're
gonna do comedy it's comedy it's a type
of comedy yeah yeah
well i would consider all right i'm
getting got me on copper cap
copper cab i consider him to be a
performance artist
yeah that's what he is and he just gets
on there to be as he's just obnoxious as
possible
and see i can't that gives me a migraine
and his
and his and his fans just sit there and
insult him
they paid it but they paid to insult him
doesn't that sound like
a weirdly sexual experience yeah they're
like you know how people
yeah it's like monica's
like farting yeah it's the culture of
that
show and that fan base i totally
understand it i totally understand
it's it's like a little mini subculture
of beating up on copper cabbage
yeah i get that i wouldn't spend my time
there but some people are into that
like i get like i said i'm not going to
hate on other people okay like his gig
if you like to do that then that's all
about you when he went like
i'm not when he when he went to when he
went to italy
what is the [ __ ] little town where
they [ __ ] got venice you showed me
like a fool all through venice and then
said yeah italy sucks and [ __ ]
he was happy to be at mcdonald's this
[ __ ] was [ __ ] hilarious i thought it
was hilarious
like i don't know that kind of [ __ ]
that's like that just get somebody when
he transitioned to female that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] hilarious
it was fake though of course this fake
that's it's like he's
although let's see his commitment to the
show do it for real [ __ ]
no it's not it's not what you're dealing
with
he's a performance artist
see meanwhile i'm over here the only
[ __ ] i watch on youtube
the only [ __ ] i watch on youtube he
watches i call like whatever i don't
know like he
he watches like a bunch of different
stuff like i call it collectively i call
it the yelling channel
i like dudes yeah because everybody's
every time i go in there no matter what
it is there's somebody's always yelling
this is by me i actually better be
yelling
i think it was a touch of satan because
like the the parents were watching
something it was on him
boy i sure do like the yelling channel
and i was like whoa that's
that's what typically you can
i can watch the yelling channel but i'll
just turn it down like halfway or put
headphones in
it's all good just don't just don't make
her watch it or someone that doesn't
want to hear it you know yeah because
i'm just kind of like bye i'm going in
here that's what volume control is for
i like i like quiet people but like um
most of the [ __ ] i watch on youtube i
watch a lot of like movie review stuff i
love
like um i mentioned before i like beer
and board games
and their other show welcome to the
basement which is a movie review show i
like uh ryan hollinger he does
movie reviews actually he does like mini
documentaries about horror movies
i like that guy um i like i just
discovered this chick called
i guess it's jordaleen or jordaline
reads
she doesn't have that many subscribers
maybe like 1500 but she reviews
books like horror books thrillers stuff
like that and she is
darling i love her but yeah so i started
watching that's where i got like a lot
of recommendations for
just saying the number of subscribers is
no indication of [ __ ]
quality you're absolutely right some of
the biggest channels are makeup channels
and i would say that's not an equality
to that but
i understand and brandon tennold yes
thank you i love him
yeah and oliver harper yeah they're very
good
they're pretty big channels though and i
think they i think they're i think those
two guys are doing well
on money i'm just saying that they're
really not as big as a makeup channel
there are makeup channels out there that
[ __ ] make a [ __ ] ton i found a
channel the other day i don't usually
like well i'll watch a makeup channel if
i need something specific like a
halloween like i need makeup that looks
like a mermaid or something like that
i'll look up one then
but i found one the other day when i was
looking for like a serial killer [ __ ] i
can't remember her name but because i
just subscribed
but it's this girl and she does like
mystery like true crime and [ __ ] but she
puts on makeup at the same time
and i was like she's really entertaining
so it's like the whole time she's like
putting on makeup and she's talking
about like [ __ ] up true crime cases
yeah it's awesome i have a background of
course as a corporate salesman so i
understand what a [ __ ] say
what what a sale is about propaganda
advertising how to [ __ ] do a pitch
how to do a sit all that [ __ ] a makeup
channel is a very good end yeah right
um because girls like makeup and they
need to know about them
but really that's like what the channel
is that's not what the channel is
the makeup is the end what the channel
really is
in some cases the ones that i'm watching
is more like just it's it's
it's offering something emotional well
yeah girls are kind of living
vicariously kind of like an online
friend
through this girl with the with the
makeup i'm talking about some of them
yeah
so everybody like you you want to like
the person's personality
oh ask a mortician yeah i love that one
oh she's cool i like her
oh and another one i like um dominic
noble he does uh
lost in adaptation he does like he talks
about like book to movie
adaptations he's really he's a british
dude but the channels like those makeup
channels i was talking about is not
surviving
on the amount of subscribers it's
it's surviving on the patrons and the
super chats
and if you look at where the patrons and
the super chats are coming for on a
makeup channel
these are girls that are not as pretty
as that girl putting on makeup
who want to be pretty as that girl and
want that girl as her first probably
dudes too though and
me and dudes that's what it is
so you have to see where the money comes
from that's why the channel exists
and there's always some kind of an alter
an ulterior motive
to a customer and it's almost always
emotional
and that's with every product i was ever
involved in and it's
normal it's not bad it's normal well
that's kind of what they tell you and
like i said i
you know i do graphic design so i'm a
little bit you know in the marketing
kind of [ __ ] too
it's like everything that brands try
they try to establish an emotional
connection
with the consumer because you're more
likely to buy the [ __ ] if you feel like
some kind of personal affinity
right with the brand or you see it as
like something that's specifically yours
or that was specifically made for you
the third 10 o'clock channel actually
what it sells is you know we do have
information
with the side tracks you got what we're
doing is we're we're professional
friends
that's that's basically what that sounds
kind of messed up
but yeah everyone is a kind of a hoe
everyone is kind of like a hooker you're
a professional friend but that's with
all of show business all of it
it's all like that i kind of feel like
it i mean i guess it sounds kind of like
i don't know just sort of crass like
saying it that way but
because honestly i like that's why i
i didn't think i would like to do like
doing the live streams because i thought
i'd be too nervous
it's better but in a lot of ways it's
better because i get to interact with
you guys and it's like it's really cool
i feel like i'm
talking to somebody instead of just like
talking into a camera like i felt like i
was just kind of talking to myself and i
felt kind of self-conscious about it
coming up from a theater background
performing in front of a live audience
is
so much easier than performing
just in front of a damn sound crew who's
[ __ ] got a camera there
because with the audience the audience
is actually looking at you
yeah you can interact right and you know
they're enjoying the show which gives
you the confidence to continue and it's
there's a synergy
in a way that's why i'm a lot more in a
way i'm a lot more impressed with people
who can act well in movies
yeah because that must be i was thinking
about that there's nobody watching well
because sometimes i watch like behind
the scenes like we were watching the
behind the scenes thing on like vivarium
yeah and they're showing like you know
like imogen poots who had to do
like the [ __ ] scene where well i'm
not going to spoil it in case anybody
succeeded but it was like a really bad
like emotional scene
and she had to do this like you know
heart-wrenching kind of thing and it's
like you have to think that
there's just like a dude sitting there
with like a camera in your face
and then like people stand over there
with lights and well there's so much
green screen nowadays i always i'm like
hmm how do you look around you and it's
just a green screen
that's what i mean it must be really
difficult so you know in a lot of ways
like if i see
like a newer movie that has like a
really like knockout
like acting performance like i forgot
that that was an actor and
i thought that was the actual character
then i think it's actually harder
nowadays because they don't usually do a
lot of [ __ ] on sets especially if it's
like a bigger movie
so it must be like really difficult to
just stand in a green room
yeah and pretend it's like hey i'm on
this other planet and like this then
there's i'm interacting with all these
aliens there's nothing there
dom the bomb says that good bad flicks
is a good show yeah it's a good channel
too yeah there's a lot of
i also like uh [ __ ] case cinema showcase
cinema he doesn't post that often no
he just took a long hiatus but i think
he just put one up a couple weeks ago
he's a british dude
yeah go check out he drinks on the show
as well [ __ ] case cinema his name's
johnny [ __ ] casey johnny [ __ ] kid that's
not his real name
he's he's also a writer yeah i meant to
like i need to buy some of his books
right because i feel like he's a horror
writer horror sci-fi fantasy kind of
[ __ ] he's a very good um youtube
character
youtube youtube if you like mst you will
probably like him because he kind of
like shows
he's kind of like the low rent british
version of mst 3k
yeah and that's what makes that show
great is that there's effort in it but
it's also
very low budget yeah and it's a it's
both things at once both things at the
same time
it's it shows you how you can make an
excellent product on youtube
with no money because you can it's
almost kind of like
it's half-assed but not half-assed on
purpose
right you know what i mean it's not that
half-assed i mean it's not that's what i
mean
yeah he obviously puts a lot of care
into it no special effects
in a way that comes across that he
doesn't put a lot of care into it
if that makes any sense does it well the
tone is
dude working from his house that's the
tone and that's that's what he rolls
with
and that's part of what makes but he's
like
that guy if he were to transport him
back
into the 80s all right he could have
played right alongside
eddie murphy and all the [ __ ] guys
from the yeah
he could have he's that funny yeah i
love that guy matter of fact he's
funnier than every eddie murphy
he might be actually yes he's funnier
than eddie murphy
just he has like really really pretty
you know he has really good comedic
timing
yeah you know what i mean and he watches
it's just like mst where he watches like
the worst like shitty movies ever and he
loves like ninja movies and all that
kind of [ __ ]
and then like he just like you know just
wails on it the whole time
junk british dude working from a council
of state that's the meat that's that's
the yeah
and he's drinking and drinking yeah he
usually has a big thing of wine or like
a big thing of beer
yeah and young yeah he's funny yeah he's
funny as [ __ ]
yeah and he has like a friend too
professor bruce that's sometimes on the
show too although he wasn't on the last
couple
oh there's somebody else i like too oh
um
i think it's called you're saying i
could i wouldn't have a problem acting
in movies and another person says i
could play snake plastic from escape
i'm gonna tell you i would love to play
snake
yeah i'm a little too short and stocky
for snake snake should be
[ __ ] kind of a little taller well i
don't know i don't i don't
know if that's the snake yeah i don't i
don't know if that is necessarily
like um you know a main thing of his
character he doesn't have to be
i don't look that good with long hair
okay that's true like you cut it yeah
yeah
i'd have to change the hair it had to
make a totally different snake
he'd have to be short-haired with a
[ __ ] eye patch
yeah almost kind of like a nick fury
yeah i could do something oh you'd be a
good nick fury too yeah
yeah now that i'm thinking about it
yeah no problem then michael says
instead of crustle we could call it
trustle
trestle yeah it's funny
oh i was gonna say another channel i
like is um i think it's called sarcastic
productions
it's like it's a girl and a guy and uh
she does like little anime like simple
animations
they either do like the the guy talks
about history
like he's like a history major and she
talks about literary tropes
and she also does um like classic
fiction like she does like greek
mythology she talks about edgar allan
poe and uh you know h.p lovecraft all
that kind of stuff
and they're they're really really good
they're really really funny i like them
as well
yeah uh xanada said i could play overly
sarcastic productions that's
it thank you yeah i really like that
channel
santa said it said i could play uh john
mccain from die hard
oh yeah i could do that that would also
be good i could do that
oh zach is here finally yeah i just said
hi jack i was talking about your gay ass
bro
i was talking about well we yeah we
needed some gay some gay information
well we were talking about
because i said something about oh my god
an amber alert oh [ __ ] amber they're
taking them children
oh no is it i haven't got one some kids
leave oh yeah i did you the kids alone
yeah it's an amber alert
yeah oh [ __ ] silver hyundai elantra
2017. you guys look out on that if
you're in orange county
yeah 11 year old got taken well that
brought that brought back
that's very sad don't don't do that i'm
down didn't it
well i'm just saying i was like i don't
get that noise i just get to like the
[ __ ] i'd love
actually if i were if you were to say
tom what movie do you want to be in
like right now all right i'd want to be
in [ __ ] expendables 4.
i can see that i would want to be in
expendables 4 because [ __ ]
lee priest is going to be in expendables
he's going to be in his panel before
far based on what he said remember i
asked him yeah i saw that and he
wouldn't tell you
you said no he kind of [ __ ] hinted
that yeah he was trying to
you said oh you should be the villain or
something he's like oh yeah it'd be more
fun than
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't
know if you guys know who lee priest is
he's a
i have bp rock australian dude yeah he's
bodybuilder [ __ ]
he's like the bodybuilder version of you
kind of he's a little shorter than me
yeah but he's got the same personality
kind of though yeah maybe
maybe he's a god he's a god dude [ __ ]
took too much roids got [ __ ]
roided out and tattooed his face he's
hilarious though
yeah most people will not tattoo you
when you're drunk yeah
he he got it burned back off you know
they asked me he says well you know i
was
i was jacked up and you know i was
i was on cycle i was interested and i
was there yeah hormonal disturbances
tattooed my face i'm gonna tattoo my
face yeah and then the other me says
yeah that's a good idea and uh lee
priest is like
he has no filter which is really fun
and he's yeah that's also like yeah he's
they're really something
he's like the famous version of you yeah
yeah why are you famous
you know what i mean like he's his face
okay
he's more famous than you sorry now i'm
gonna get
i gotta get in the pissing match with
lee priest [ __ ] come on the show bro
oh [ __ ]
i get called out you're shorter than me
lee
oh no when you call him he's starting to
[ __ ] he'll come on the show
so come on the show if you start talking
about oh my god that'd be awesome that's
why i did it he's only in shorter than
me
he's only been shorter maybe two maybe
two [ __ ]
he is he in the 40s maybe he's yeah no
no he's
almost 50 i think a little bit he may be
like one or two years younger than me
i think he's okay so like my age he's in
good shape yeah basically
he's really rude he's genetically his
yeah
tell them what he looked like when he
was about 30. he was like
lit wasn't he competing when he was like
18 yeah his mom
was 20. his mom was a bodybuilder yeah i
don't know what the [ __ ] is dad did but
his mom was
and he was like enormous when he was
like 18
20 years old competing and [ __ ] so he
had he had per
janette his genetics were perfect for
bodybuilding and he had the right face
for it he looks like a gorilla
he looked like a little blonde yeah a
blonde girl a little blonde
he was a very aryan looking guy yeah it
was as if
the [ __ ] ss supermen were trying to
breed
a race of gorillas yup that's what
[ __ ]
lee priest look like i will breed a
bracelet we will greet a race of
gorillas
yeah well if he ends up being in the
expendables movie then everyone will see
what you're talking about
i would play i would love to play right
alongside [ __ ] lee priest in the
[ __ ]
one of his goons yeah sidekick because
physically me and him would be
good in the shot together just because
of the height similarity
you look and we put on that but you look
so small yeah yeah
yeah and we put it we put on put on
[ __ ] some ballistic armor and get
some 16s and do some [ __ ]
you guys could be like twins right and
you could be like sort of but he's like
huge oh he's [ __ ] no he's like his
arms
are his arms are like this big yeah zach
said you would be a good james bond
henchman
yeah maybe yeah maybe or michael says
you would be a good bot
good a bad guy or a sidekick in conan
three
there's not gonna be a conan three i
wish there would be
yeah but we're being hypothetical here
don't [ __ ] on everyone's corn flakes
they've got the right mindset i mean
yeah yeah
i would like to be in expendables four
that's what if i could be in a movie
i'd be in that one okay so if anybody
like anything to do with expendables for
yeah i'd like to work for how what's
your fee
i don't need money oh [ __ ] he'll do it
for a while volunteer for that
he'll do it for free i don't need any
money
just pay for your hotel and food and
stuff oh the army still
pays me i'm retired
david june says can we get tom to play
steven seagal
you need to eat you need to eat a whole
bunch of donuts
that's a good question oh you have to
get fat you don't want that that's a
good question i'll put a fat suit on
i'll put a fast suit on and i'll dye my
scalp
i could play steven seagal all day well
all they have to do is do your eyes
that's all they film is your eyes
okay yeah yeah i can wear
i'll wear a stack shoes and a fat suit
and a mustache and a beard and i'll just
sit in the chair
and mumble it people have your stunt
double walk up and down the stairs for
you
yeah done and i'm gonna watch us i'll do
it for
half of the fee of whatever his stunt
doubles are doing
she's never seen a cigar but we have to
see it under siege you have to see under
siege
you gotta add to your piles yeah steven
seagal is not fat in that one though no
that's
understanding that was actually his only
thing he's best work
that's his only good movie hard to kill
was pretty good
it's okay hard to kill in under siege i
gotta agree to disagree okay
no yeah
um actually under siege is i can watch
it
but it's kind of i can watch it for like
irony like mst
well that's what you do yeah that's what
we did back then though kind of true
but you know people were telling me i
was a south camp in egypt you know
[ __ ]
101st and dudes were telling me that he
was an ex-navy seal and i'm watching
that and i was going well yeah he wanted
that that's it
you're like and then i saw him run and i
was like no
no there's gifts of that [ __ ] no you're
not the only person
and i kept two i could notice i kept
looking at his biceps during these
scenes and i was lying like
he hasn't done any push-ups he runs so
weird why does he run like that
navy seal because in the time that i was
in
i mean i don't know people but navy
seals
army ragers special forces
they were the [ __ ] top top top they
were like pro ball
players not to [ __ ] on the dudes of
today
but after the [ __ ] afghan war and the
two iraq wars
they were having problems guys kept
leaving you know leaving service because
they were over deploying them
so the quality kind of declined
it declined to the part where i could
bend special forces you know
during the time i was in i would i could
never be special forces
that the competition was too tough they
were only taking the very very top
but you know got to the it got to the
point where it was about as bad as
vietnam in vietnam if you wanted to
fight you could be in special forces
pretty much
because nobody wanted to go well yeah so
you know
i actually respected those guys a lot
you know even from the vietnam era
maybe they weren't up to the same
physical specs but
they were bad too you know
yeah they were [ __ ] fighting
steven seagal though what about it
yeah xander says hard to kill was good
i don't honestly i don't remember a lot
about it because i feel like a lot of
those
um a lot of those movies kind of blend
into one big long movie
for me you know what i mean yeah because
they're all kind of about the same thing
and
i had it you know i've mentioned this
before on the show my ex-husband was
super super into like 80s action movies
particularly chuck norris but also
stephen cigal some other things
so i saw like all of them so i feel like
i so i feel like not very many of them
stood out
you know what i mean because they were
all kind of samey but
um the only chuck norris movie that i
actually like
legitimately is silent rage because that
wasn't really
an action movie it was more like a
serial killer which one was that
silent rage chuck norris was in it oh
okay
i didn't see that one that's honestly i
think well the octagon was okay too but
um
silent rage was actually i don't know if
it was even intended for chuck norris to
start with
but it's actually kind of like a
genetically enhanced serial killer story
more than a chuck norris kicking
everyone's asses story
so i think that's probably why i like
that one because it was something else
going on
yeah because you know i'd watch all the
chuck norris movies i'm like oh here's
his big hairy chest again oh here he
comes oh yeah there he goes okay he's
beating everyone up
the end yay
you know i never got into chuck norris i
didn't either i didn't really get like i
mean i don't know my ex-husband was
really into martial arts so i guess
that's kind of why
because he was really into bruce lee too
i was like i like the bruce lee movies
but
i don't know chuck norris just always
pissed me off for some reason but silent
rage was good
and i think that actually might be on to
be
for free at the moment it's rendezvous
with destiny michael
ronavoo but that was just 101st
yeah lone wolf lone wolf mcquaid is
actually pretty good
i remember that one kind of
his wig is bad chuck norris's
i doesn't have a wig now i don't even
know like
i don't know i remember him being kind
of a douche i remember him not having
much of a sense of humor about [ __ ]
didn't i mention this on the show before
i feel like there was this guy that made
his living as a chuck norris
impersonator
and then chuck norris like was gonna sue
him
because he's like well nobody can be me
do you need to take a break do you uh
jim
i probably do i probably would you take
a break for a second all right i'm gonna
you i gotta go there any commercials
oh yeah yeah oh okay so i got all my
footage
we gotta show these sophie took both of
these okay yeah i'm gonna show i'm gonna
show them right now
there's one of pokey and there's the
things i see around here
i know it's like i'm really glad that
you got the pookie one particularly
because i've always tried to film her
doing that and i can't ever
she showed me they'll see what you're
talking about but she showed me she's
like look look look
i'm like oh that's pretty cool every
time you guys as soon as you see it
every time i refill this water jug she
comes running because she hears it
so yeah all right so let me do well let
me do the faceless spelling commercial i
don't have to do the strange realities
commercial anymore because that's
over now well it's not over it's going
on right now but by the time this goes
up it's over
all right but i'll do this commercial
and then wait are you going to be here
to like do the video or
yeah are you leaving too what video this
one
i have to like go to the next one you
know what i'm saying you can show me
okay go to like yeah fv commercial is
what i'm on now and then at the bottom
is
pookie water jug and beijing love okay
that's at the bottom
pookie and then beijing yeah it's at the
bottom of the list right here
you see what i'm saying okay all right
so we'll be right back we'll be back in
just a few
minutes you love true crime
i love true crime and i've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing
unsolved murders of the 20th century
it's called the faceless villain
and volume 3 is available now featuring
such fascinating cases as the ketty
murders the carrie babies
case the frog boys the alcasar murders
and the anoka shira park dismemberment
incident
the faithless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999.
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com
and get ready for a chilling journey
through modern crime history
yeah you got it
get the bubbles
so
oh it's going on the floor
you goof
hey
all right we're back see weren't those
those cat videos are delightful yeah
that's what i get to experience guys she
likes how you smell
i told you she loves you like as soon as
you got here it was just kind of like
she's like i love you i'm adopting
that's what beijing does
yeah with all my stuff and me she ran up
and hugged her yeah
trying to climb up her oh oh like trying
to like cram her face
she's like i love you
it's not just nice to feel appreciated
by you you're very pretty
i'm gonna put some more of this damn
kayla in there oh you brought the whole
bottle in here look at this [ __ ] he's
going all
in yeah they're saying that i am done
well it is water
it is my birthday so i i don't want to
get too [ __ ]
up though because i did drink last night
and i was like really tired but you know
what i mean
there and you're saying i should play
roy batty yeah there you go
yeah i could play roy you could
oh i need to put some orange in there
you want to go get some orange
go ahead and run a show all right all
right so the next case we're going to
talk about how many more do i have okay
so i only have two more
that's good the next one's short and
then like there's kind of a long one
this
i actually had an actual like another
one but i was like hearing tom's voice
in the back of my head as i often do
as you guys could probably imagine and
um he was like that's too many
you overdid it blah blah so it's like so
i took one out like
five minutes before we turned on because
i was like i know how this is gonna go
and uh i'm just gonna take this one out
because it's gonna take too long
but the next one that i wanna talk about
was this was actually i thought they
were all american but this one is
actually not this is from switzerland
and this is called
le loyal now this is a guy
who was an urban legend for a long time
about this dude who was walking around
in the woods and he was wearing like
uh a gas mask and cam
camouflage and apparently he would like
walk around in the woods like on this
path
like on the same path like all the time
and some people would like randomly see
him
and then you know they he you know they
would just like get a glimpse of him
like people would just get a glimpse and
be like what
there was a dude over there like with a
gas mask and leg with camo on
so for a long time people thought he was
like a ghost
or like an urban legend or something
because you would only see him for like
a second like you'd be in the woods
you'd be out hiking or whatever
and you would see this weird dude like
walking around in the woods
with a gas mask on but then
somebody took a photo of him and i'm
i don't know if this is the photo but
this is a photo of him
right here and there he is
so he's actually like a real guy
now apparently this dude had been
walking around out in the woods and he
was in switzerland for 10 years without
anybody taking a picture of him
because i guess he was really good at
hiding plus he had camo on so you know
um so yeah 10 years no one had taken a
picture of him
and he apparently walked around the same
areas though like every day but it was
kind of like remote i guess
so apparently one woman said that she
had seen him and he was out there and he
was like he had
a like a bundle of flowers in his hand
and she saw him for a second and then
like he disappeared
now they started calling what was that
was that oh okay
i heard the door creak like she's like
what are you guys doing in here
what are you doing baby girl so
apparently a bunch of people have seen
her like pull that you know
had seen this dude and like the police
would be called and stuff but oh my god
hey girl girl that's some wrapping paper
oh she
yeah yeah you got it
yeah so but no one had taken a picture
of him so like the police were just like
oh you're imagining it or whatever
but then once the picture came out and
it like ran in the paper
um after that happened
girl you gotta let go oh
she's trying to step on it and not let
me take it
that's what she does every time i try to
make the bed come here she's like i'm
helping
no don't take the sheets just go play
with that out there you can have it
yeah you can play with that out there
poo she's like where are you taking my
phone
yeah yeah yeah look there you go yay
there you go you just don't get an
audience
she's like oh it's not fun though no
it's like she's gonna do it around us
but yeah so they published the guy's um
photo like the person had taken a photo
of him and they published it in the
paper
and then shortly after that there were
some hikers out in these woods
and they found the gas mask
and the camo are like the leather that
the guy had been wearing
and they just found it laying there like
without a guy in it
and then they found a note with it
and the note said it was titled the
death certificate
and testament of the ghost of malls
which i guess was the name of the forest
so i guess
this guy basically was like i was just a
dude who lived out in the woods
and wanted to be left alone and now
someone has seen me
so basically you guys have killed me
or you guys have made me move somewhere
else because he's like i just wanted to
walk around in the woods and not bother
anybody
but now everybody is like all up in my
[ __ ] because they think i'm like
a ghost or an urban legend or something
like that so
i don't know if he died or if you know
or i don't know if he was just like
being a drama queen or something like
that with the whole death certificate
thing but he left a note like with the
gas mask and was like well [ __ ] it you
guys ruined it
i'm out and that's what he ended
apparently he's never been seen since
then
um so yeah he was just like this weird
dude that lived out in the woods and
wanted to be alone and i guess we
couldn't even do that for him
so people saw him and took pictures of
him and he got like pissed off about it
so the last case i want to talk about
this one's a little bit
kind of a long one we're almost at three
hours though
david june says it's been more than 10
years since someone took a picture of me
take a selfie yeah you can do that wait
does that count that's like
that's not somebody else taking this but
yeah all right so
this urban legend which is kind of a
better known one
so for a long time there was a
an urban legend or a series of urban
legends that circulated around
about um somebody that would go like a
in a carnival fun house
and there was like a you know like a
decoration in there that looked like a
corpse or a skeleton or something like
that like hanging from the rafters
and it turned out that it was real thank
you ken
because it's only money and you guys
rock oh thank you thanks kim appreciate
it
ken my favorite was predator one
off-brand movie favorite one be escaped
from new york
uh i also like predators which is like
what predator three
predators i like that one that was a
good one too see wait i get confused
because there was the predators and then
there was
the predator that was like predator four
that's what i'm saying which was that's
the thing it's like when you get
into that it's like name the [ __ ]
different yeah
name the [ __ ] different yeah i can't
differentiate avp one and two better
than the predator
a lot of people talking [ __ ] about avp
one and two i like those
they were all right i saw the first one
in the theater i think yeah
the second one was low budget but i must
say i still liked it i don't remember
this
it was like i might have seen it like
another movie but i don't remember bonus
movie
i don't take any of that [ __ ] seriously
some people take this [ __ ] too seriously
i feel i feel like you kind of do take
it there you take this [ __ ] seriously
that's what it is but i'm not going to
sit here and go it's too dark
it's too dark they [ __ ] up that this
and that
it was a low budget movie they didn't
want you to see how bad the [ __ ]
effects sucked yeah that's like an old
school trick right if your monster looks
shitty and if it's just made of tinfoil
and spit you really need to like shoot
the whole thing in the dark
they tried to give you the most
expansive story that they could for the
money that they had and
so i understand it's just a movie they
can make another one
okay get back to get back and get back
to it it's just a movie we just think
i'm just moving i'm sorry about i'm
sorry about interrupting the the flow of
the movie
the flow of the movie it's slow is this
a movie the flow of the [ __ ]
i don't have a flow anymore [ __ ] joke
okay i can't have a flower can't have a
flow i [ __ ]
it's a it's a [ __ ] it's a show
yeah it's a show man
it's a show it's a movie that's like uh
that's like what we said on that movie
review the other day we're like you know
it's a movie
yeah we were like we should put that in
a movie we should
be right we should put the dvd cover at
least it's a movie
well not all movies can say that so it
is
it is kind of a compliment so yeah so
we've all heard the stories about
the uh creepily realistic mannequin
and somebody in the comments already
knows what i'm gonna talk about they saw
that
um you know you go through a fun house
at a carnival or whatever and you see
like a body or something hanging and
it's like wow that looks really real
and the urban legend was that there was
one that was really real except it
wasn't an urban legend
it really did happen so what ends up
happening
is there's this guy named elmer mccurdy
and he was like this dude back in the
wild west he was like a wannabe
gunslinger except he wasn't super good
at it
like you know what i mean he was one of
those dudes that like tried to rob banks
and he [ __ ] it up
and he tried to like do that kind of
[ __ ] he [ __ ] it up and uh
he ended up being probably the most
famous
uh corpse in america i guess for a time
because man his body got up all up to
all kind of shenanigans
like uh posthumously so
it was a couple of weeks before
christmas in 1976. this is how this [ __ ]
got discovered
so cast and crew of the six million
dollar man show
uh they were actually filming a an
episode at queen's park in long beach
california where you were from
yeah now the episode was called carnival
of spies
so they're filming a scene inside of a
fun house
at long beach yeah at the pike yeah
yeah that's where they had their real
dead body that's what we're talking
about
yeah yeah i saw it's like five minutes
later he's like oh you're well dead
yes that's what i'm talking about okay
look when i was a little kid i saw this
i already saw this there was in the fun
house
there was a bunch of weird [ __ ]
happening and one of them was a [ __ ]
was what was a dead body that they
showed you
in the ride during the fun house and i
saw it
and it [ __ ] spooky it turned out that
[ __ ] was a dead body
that's what i mean that's what i mean
that's why sometimes
urban legends it's like into the earth
then and subsequently like an urban
legend spread around the country
i didn't know that like in every fun
house it's like oh thank you very much
dom
thanks don and you know who saw it with
me who's that
rodney allen rippy wait who who am i
right now rippy was a little serial
that's the serial killer thing rodney
allen rippy was a minor celebrity in la
at the time he was there at the same
time with me i was there
i was aware of my mom and he was there
with his mom and he was a little black
kid
that was the spokesman for [ __ ] oh
right right right you told me about him
okay everybody loved i didn't remember
his name
everybody loved at that time back in the
70s he was in the jack in the box
he was in the jack-in-the-box
commercials and rodney allen rippy
that's right just go on [ __ ] youtube
and looking at old jack
jack in the box commercial rodney allen
and at the time you know i was like
five all right he was the same age as me
and i love the michael jack the jackson
fives okay i was big into the jackson
fives like
[ __ ] singing along with the tv
and for some reason when i met rodney
i thought he was in the jackson five too
i did not differentiate between white
there was black kid okay it would have
been funnier
i couldn't i couldn't differentiate
between rodney allen
and michael jackson and when i say
michael jackson i'm talking about
well a kid michael little kid michael
jackson he was a little bit older than
me
but yeah i saw him both on television
all the time
so therefore they're the same person or
they knew each other or that they
knew each other just because everybody
on tv lives in yeah i live in the tv box
like the tiny people that live so when i
saw rodney
and his mom i felt like i was meeting
the jackson fives
and uh abc we went through that ride
together he was in the [ __ ] buggy in
front of me yeah
so he saw it with me and you guys
creeped out you guys are you telling me
you know that that was a real dead body
because i thought it was fake because it
totally was i thought it was everyone
thought it was fake
well it was all fake you're a kid you're
like five or six
so you just think it's part of the ride
well yeah everybody was scared that's
what they tell you when you're scared
your parents always say oh don't
exactly exactly it's not real but here
was the funny thing about it
about five years later when i was 10 or
11 my mom i was
this is when i was riding horses my mom
was already in the english equestrian
scene and everything i was already
jumping and my mom goes
and she's calling me tommy tommy yeah
hold on oh tom
tommy oh my god doesn't that sound like
her yeah i was just like oh my god
do you know what's so weird do you
remember that my mother's like a [ __ ]
total valley girl
my mom is the [ __ ] my mom is doing it
sounds just like
i gotta get a picture of my mom on the
show when she was [ __ ] like
my mom was the cassandra peterson or the
elvira of [ __ ] l.a
she dated [ __ ] famous dudes and [ __ ]
wayne newton right
yeah well among others robert goulet
anyway robert they look kind of the same
my mom had
double g [ __ ] breasts she was a
little short [ __ ] thing and she
looked like
cassandra peterson back in those days oh
tom do you remember at the pike
remember when we were in the fun house
and you saw the dead body
all the scary stuff in there it was
really a dead body
oh my god i can totally see her doing
that yeah
that's exactly what that's exactly what
his mom sounds like
it was really a dead body it was such as
insane
my mother's my mother's [ __ ]
histrionic personality is a [ __ ]
disorder
[ __ ] chain all right
oh everything is showing very very
little substance
dramatic very dramatic but but yeah one
of these days i'll [ __ ] show up his
mom but she looked like that she was
yeah
you'll see yeah she was like i said she
attracted a lot of attention back in
those days
so like i said with the rumor was that
she that she slept with robert coulee no
she did
she did yeah that wasn't a rumor she
actually did no she didn't
yeah maybe charles bronson she knew him
and for the horse business but i don't
know probably not probably not
my mom was [ __ ] famous in vegas yeah
she was [ __ ] dating whoever was big
in vegas at the time she would have gone
after elvis if she could have
but she was [ __ ] whoever was
headlining in vegas my mom was trying to
date that
yeah yeah all right so how about sig
freedom roy
they were gay are they yeah they're gay
they were married didn't one of them get
eaten by a tiger yeah yeah
and roy were married to each other oh i
didn't know that yeah i don't know a lot
about secretary
yeah i'm i'm more of a pen and teller
person myself so yeah
but yeah so so they're filming this
episode of the six million dollar man
in this [ __ ] fun house in long beach
and you know they're using the existing
[ __ ] that was in
the fun house which you would presume
would be fake
but uh what ended up happening was that
i guess like the
there was like a breeze or something and
it sends this corpse
uh you know kind of swinging back and
forth which i think is a fake corpse
and they um the wax the arm like broke
off
and now they thought it was made of wax
or whatever
but so they're like oh we need to fix
that like for the next scene and then
they're like hey
there's a bone in here yeah so that's
how they discovered
yeah that this was actually a real
per it was mummified so this guy that
had died it's like he
i think he was mummified down to like he
was only like 50 pounds or something
and it was like he was like five foot
three see like shrunk down yeah
because he'd been like uh you know gone
he'd gone around like so many different
carnivals and [ __ ] like that
yeah the storm mom told me that he was
some kind of gangster that the [ __ ]
vibe had killed
no is that true that's not what happened
he was um he was more like a wild west
kind of
failed criminal okay a little bit all
right
more elmo is his name so he wasn't even
from the [ __ ] gangster era no no no
okay um yeah basically
so they they were like okay so the crew
of the show it's like they see the bone
in there and they're like holy [ __ ] this
is a real body
so they did what a normal person would
do they call like the police and the
ambulance
so and so the paramedics get there
and they're like okay well
i think that the crew told them that
it's like he looks like he died of
dehydration or something because he was
so small like
yeah and that was like when the
paramedics got there they cracked up
because they're like yeah he's
dehydrated already he's [ __ ]
mummified
so they found out they took him to the
coroner's office
and they found out that the cause of
death was there was a bullet lodged in
his chest and it was a turn of the
century
bullet so it was like you know late 19th
century early 20th century
bullet so as i said the mummy was
5'3 50 pounds so now
it didn't have like i guess it had been
like
over the time that it had been i think
it had been in the long beach fun house
for four years but i prior to that i
guess they found out later that it had
been
like kind of gone to other fun houses
and like sideshows and stuff
um he didn't have like some of his
fingers were missing some of his toes
were missing
um you know some of the hair was missing
[ __ ] like that they had actually
somebody at one point had drilled a hole
through his neck so they could put the
noose around him and i guess whoever had
drilled the hole in the neck like a
bunch of like
gross yellow [ __ ] had come out which i
guess was spinal fluid but they didn't
really think about it at the time
i don't know because nobody said
anything about it then so
they also found and this was pretty
creepy they found inside
the mouth of the corpse they found
um a ticket to the museum of crime
and they also found a penny in there
which was dated from 1924.
so then as they started like looking
back into
you know how that [ __ ] got there they
figured out like where this dude came
from
so they found out so this guy
elmer mccurdy they found out was this
dude's name
now he was actually born in 1880 so this
is
like i said this was kind of longer ago
i guess he could have still been
gangster but it was earlier than that
so basically he goes to he
like kind of had a [ __ ] up childhood
he turned into a drifter
and then he was going out west like a
lot of people were at that time
and he um was kind of also a drunk
so he was trying to you know keep hold
jobs and he couldn't really do it so he
kept getting like kind of kicked out
um he was also in the army for four
years he lived in the midwest
and then he decided that he was going to
like he learned how to use like
nitroglycerin and like how to make
explosives and stuff
so he decided that he was gonna get in
with a criminal outfit
and like you know do like train hold ups
and whatnot like using
bombs i guess so he was like trying to
do that
like railroad robberies but it turned
out that he wasn't
um real good at it he also tried to do
like safe cracking and stuff like that
but he wasn't super good at that
either um he also got
so like he was kind of a dude that you
know have you ever seen like the dumb
criminals kind of [ __ ] like the books
about it and all that kind of [ __ ]
he was kind of that kind of person like
he would try to do these big
elaborate schemes and he would always
get caught or he would like he would get
caught in a really stupid way
like he gets caught for public
intoxication
um and they find that he has like a
whole bunch of like burglary tools
like on him um during a train heist
he was trying to like blow
the safe open and he instead like blew
the whole thing up
which had like you know what i mean so
it had like four thousand dollars in it
which i guess
like in back then money which was like a
lot of money and he ended up blowing the
safe up and like there was silver bars
in it and they ended up like
melting a lot of them so he ended up
getting away with like maybe 450
instead of 4 000. um so it was that kind
of [ __ ] like he would try to like blow
up
like blow the lock off a vault and he
would just like blow the whole [ __ ]
thing up and like dump [ __ ] like that
um so basically he
uh for the last like the railroad like
heist that he had done
he finally gets like a 2 000
bounty put on his head right so
he also wasn't real good as like even
though he
sort of prided himself as like a
gunslinger he wasn't he was like a
really shitty
shot also so there was also that
now uh in 1911
i guess he was on a heist with like a
bunch of other dudes
and they had stolen some alcohol and
some other things
and all of his buddies like i guess he
was drunk or he had some other problem
and they all like
left him behind so he goes to hide in
some hay shed
somewhere and a bunch of sheriffs with
bloodhounds
found him and he started shooting at the
cops
and they ended up shooting him dead
so basically what they did after that so
there was i guess there was a thing
where if somebody was shot like a
criminal and they were
shot and this is going back to the civil
war
what would happen was that dudes that
made their living as embalmers
like if a body was unclaimed as elmer
mccurdy's was
they would actually like embalm the body
and then they would put it on display
at the at their mortuary like as an
advertisement
kinda and also just in case like
somebody that knew this dude would like
happen by and like identify him but also
because look how good my embalming is
thank you
thank you thank you thank you who's that
i can't read them john ablana
all right john hablana bladder blah i
keep
i keep wanting to put another end in
there i don't know why that is
thank you very much anna yeah so that
was a thing that they did as like an
advertised like look
look how good our embalming services is
and this dude's not identified so they
figured they could like experiment or
whatever so
basically they put him out as an
advertisement
uh in this um in this mortuary in
oklahoma and no one identified him
so at this point like the dude that had
done the embalming was kind of like well
you know i did this work on this dude so
i'd really like to get some compensation
for it and no one is coming to
claim him so basically
they're like maybe we can put him on
display and people will like pay to come
see him so i can get some money back for
this embalming work
that he's done so that's what ended up
happening
like he ends up getting sold to various
crime museums
side shows things like that and he's
billed as different stuff you know what
i mean
so the reason why this guy ended up
having coins and [ __ ] like that his
mouth was that
he would he was when he was at the crime
museum
the kind of like uh one of their
gimmicks was that you paid your
your fee or your fare like for getting
into the museum by putting the coin
into the dude's mouth and i guess one of
the coins was still
in there like you know from that time
period
so basically like this dude's body
went all [ __ ] over and he got passed
like from carnival to carnival all over
the country
um you know basically
i like kind of lost my place on the
notes there you guys are just like all
quiet
it's all right that's that was about the
end of it anyway right
pretty much i mean basically it just
ended up that
he just went from sideshow to sideshow
and
eventually the knowledge that that was
actually a real dead body
yeah got lost over the years as it would
because
you know you wouldn't think you know
when you're selling your stock to like
the next [ __ ]
yeah thing down the line mango badger's
in man it's good to see you back mango
yay during the time a mom told me about
this
like i said it was the 70s i think it
was like uh 77
76 yeah because it was 76 when they
filmed the show and that was when they
first discovered that he was an
actual body okay so that my memory is
correct then
because i remember the era between 76
and 77 because i remember what stable we
were at
you know where the horses were um
that's when she told me about it and at
that time the scuttle but there's no
internet and of course people didn't
really trust the news or the tr
the news was you know not trustworthy
during that time thank you victor holy
crap
buy yourself a cake you don't have to
fart on it
yeah i think i'll refrain thank you so
much
that's a [ __ ] great present um
during that time what the [ __ ]
word on the street was is that it was a
real dead body being concealed
in the fun house by some gangsters that
killed a dude alone right
that was the story i heard too but the
the but that the fun house wasn't aware
that it was real until
they moved it and it broke they thought
it was something
yeah they were sold as a prop yeah and
they thought and they thought it was
something from the 20s
yeah from the gangster era of the 20s of
california
which that kind of makes sense but it
wasn't right
but it's close though yeah and i do feel
like as i said this
guy's corpse had been had gone to so
many different sideshows and stuff
that i think by the time that the
funhouse in long beach got it
i don't think they were aware that that
was a real body anymore they just
thought it was like a hang because it
was mummified
so they just thought oh neat it's like a
realistic
like [ __ ] corpse that's just like
hanging there
so i don't think anybody really thought
that it was a real dead body
yeah um i'm surprised this doesn't
happen more often because like i said
it it does really seem like this kind of
thing where
like embalmers would do the work on
somebody that was unidentified
and then they'd be like hey i need to
like make some money off this [ __ ] so
they would like
end up selling it to like sideshows and
stuff if nobody claimed it because what
the [ __ ] else are you gonna do with it
it's just laying around
so yeah so he went all around the
country and then um
he was part of the uh traveling the
museum of crime like i said that was the
tickets and stuff they found in his
mouth that was a traveling museum that
um was in 1922.
and then he um was also in a side show
that was uh with the transamerican foot
race in 1928
so he's just like going all around the
country this is my favorite though
so in the 1930s in 1933
you know when there was the all those
like um scaremongering
drug movies you know what i mean like
[ __ ] reefer madness and all that
other kind of stuff
well there was one that came out in 1933
called narcotic
and they actually bought or rented
elmer mccurdy's corpse i guess not
knowing it was a corpse i don't know if
they knew or not
for the like promotional materials for
this movie
so they basically would prop the corpse
up in the lobby
of the [ __ ] theater show in this
movie and would say that this guy
was a dope fiend and was uh
yeah so it's like so it's like that was
something that they used to sell the
movie they were like trying to scare
people like don't do drugs kids or
you'll end up like this dude right here
that's like propped up it was an actual
corpse but like i said i don't know they
might have done it was an actual corpse
that seemed like some [ __ ] people would
do in the 30s
like nowadays if people be like no i'm
not going to do that but but oh my god
another yeah
they want to leave those kids alone guys
are they really
serious it might be the same one
let me see it's another amber alert is
it now let me clear something up jen
that sophie's talking about in the um
discussion
somebody asked somebody said something
about the pr someone that played
the john convention was the predator
right you're right only in some shots
yeah yeah the guy who played the
predator was at the very end of the
movie when they're [ __ ] when after
the atomic bomb goes off
you see him flying away in the
helicopter the helicopter pilot got a
tall black guy [ __ ] flying the
helicopter
that's the guy that mostly was the
predator
okay that was the that that was the
presence okay well i thought it was what
you're talking about
is that there are certain shots where
the predator is throwing arnold
schwarzenegger all around during the
jungle during the last fight
jean claude van damme was was the stunt
double
okay for arnold schwarzenegger during
those fight scenes oh hold on shauna
brinkley said are we talking about billy
syrian yes that's her that's who i'm
talking about the the girl that puts on
makeup and talks about true crime
thank you somebody remember okay so in
some
the reason why is because one
you don't want [ __ ] arnold to get
hurt during all those stunts
two gene claude von dam is smaller than
arnie and he made the predator look
bigger during the hand-to-hand fighting
so you got it only
partly right what was that jean-claude
played isn't there footage of like the
original predator and he's all
like he looks like a [ __ ] lobster
okay okay that that's him right
that predator the prototype predator the
predator that got
cut from the movie uh was a suit that
had vandam in it
that's what i was thinking of yeah yeah
but that entire
monster got cut okay so because it was
dorky
it was a bad looking lobster like a
man-sized lobster yeah
it was red because it had to do with
some green screen effects and some weird
not green yeah i think it was green
no it had to do with the damn cloaking
effect yeah
they wanted it to and red was the best
color to work out for that
um it's just that that costume didn't
look good and they scrapped it it did
have van damme in it but
none of that made it into the movie
although van damme playing dutch
being thrown around by the predator he's
in it okay
okay so yeah that's what i thought i
didn't get a lot of stuff he did a lot
of stunt work on it
yeah he was he was the the first
predator yeah
but the first predator was totally cut
from the movie okay
yeah because if you see like the extra
footage from that that first monster
looked
relatable it didn't look that bad
when it wasn't moving when it moved just
let it stay let the monster just stand
still
it looks much better when it's standing
still well i think the idea came from
drawings
when they drew it yeah it looked it's
one thing having the drive
and then they made it move it into a
suit and move it around
it didn't look that good the head was
still small on it like a little
like a little dog head or a little
[ __ ] yeah that was super weird
like a vulture thinking on a big body
but i saw drawings of what they were
drawn before they made it and
the drawings looked pretty good but like
i said it's easy to draw something you
need to draw free
like when you actually have to make it
right that's a whole other catalog they
scrap that [ __ ] and they [ __ ] gave
the whole
monster design to a kid working out of
his goddamn garage with no experience
that he knocked it
out of the [ __ ] park well
that's still
that's still one of the best monsters
that predator one suit to this day
i was there in the theater watching it
when it was just released
and when that thing took that mask off
i've never seen anything like it i
thought i just saw a [ __ ] alien
i was like that's what it that's what an
alien well it was genius doing the [ __ ]
with the mandible it looked real
that was like a really though and it
looks better than the a
than the predator and predator 2 and it
looked better just the way they
shot it and and and i think it's a
different costume in certain movies
that particular costume just looked real
it looks really good in that format
the way it was shot in that lighting
condition it just looked real to me the
map the mask all the prosthetics like
looked really good
and they got that guy that was like he
was like a dancer or something like that
and they put that guy in the suit
right somebody's asking if i will
refrain refrain from what
that's a long list of things he should
refrain from
johnny's got a list all kinds of [ __ ]
i'm supposed to be refraining from that
i ain't gonna refrain
that's not what i'm here for he's not
here for refraining i'm not here for
refrain
he's here for indulging he pushes the
boundary
you have to understand something the
creator has created
all of us to do certain things that's
true
and each of us are doing our things they
may not be the same things
they're different things okay and that's
the way the universe is supposed to work
time's going to time what's that i'm
going to talk about it
yeah and [ __ ] everybody's going to do
you know that's how that's how it is
yeah it's an entire symphony
of people doing whatever the [ __ ]
they're gonna do
just find your people and make it work
that's beautiful thomas
you like that [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] waxy
poetic man
it's the alcohol i've become a sage of
the ages
must say we are all just part of the
[ __ ] symphony of reality
we're living in the age of aquarius
[Music]
that guy's got such a deep voice yeah
that that head hockman was like [ __ ]
awesome
michael uh i can't remember that british
actor he's [ __ ] funny
happy birthday jenny you look like
you're 25. thank you
thank you very much love bear butt love
bear butt
we were talking about butts earlier you
might have missed it
but yeah so so this guy gets propped up
in movie theaters he gets like
put on top of a car like the corpse and
uh national lampoon's vacation
kind of like that uh he was also um
there was a movie that came out in 1967
called
she freak which was like a carnival
horror film and he was also a prop
for that now he got sold in like a bulk
you know purchase to the hollywood wax
museum
and i guess they didn't put him on
display at that wax because they thought
he was like wear it out they're like wow
this this
wax dummy looks really shitty so we're
not putting this one on because it was
in a lot with a bunch of other ones
so they're like well not printing this
one i don't think they thought that it
was a real body but they just thought it
looked like crap so they didn't put it
on display
now a couple years later he gets bought
by
the uh fun house in long beach
california which was called
queen's park laugh in the dark
laugh with two f's which is stupid as
[ __ ]
is this like a little carnival area or
something so yeah it's a fun park
yeah it's a fun park so yeah so they
just like hung him up in there and for
like four years people are going through
this fun house going woo look at this
scary corpse and then like they film six
million dollar marine in there and then
his arm breaks off and they're like oh
[ __ ] there's a bone in there see there's
somebody chimed in there
gordon's alive what was that
motherfucker's name his name was michael
something rather
yes i know i like i know who you were
talking about i know
that guy's name and put that in the
comments my brain is too pickled at the
moment
yeah he's a british actor he's a [ __ ]
good little dude i saw i saw some
interviews with him
he's [ __ ] hilarious talking about all
the outtakes from that [ __ ] scene
where he's running along the wing
[ __ ] with his ray gun going he was
taking his acting really seriously
but what was funny is they had to retake
it because he was actually going
out of his mouth well how can you not
yeah and it was like don't stop
saying this stop doing it we're gonna
add the sound effect in later
it's like quick on pew pew knock it off
about the uh acting when you don't have
like brian blessed thank you brian
blessing that's what his name is brian
i knew i knew that [ __ ] yeah brian
blessed yeah you said michael but okay i
was thinking mike brian brian blessed
that
michael bryant that's kind of the same
brian bless no no no no you said bless
it and it all came back
that dude that [ __ ] played clydus was
the [ __ ] too he was in a bunch of sinbad
movies from sinbad the [ __ ]
eye of the tiger and sinbad and the i
loved those little british sinbad movies
one of them had [ __ ] tom baker from
doctor who in it
yeah i did he was like he was a bad guy
right he played the [ __ ] yeah he
played the dance
evil sorcerer yeah i think that was
sinbad in the eye the tiger i think
i saw that in the theater i saw him in
the theater and little kimmy took me to
see it man my little
little kid my little hot babysitter
[ __ ] back when i was a little kid
my little princess leia took me and i
was [ __ ] up here holding her hand and
[ __ ]
i thought it was so scary
that you took her and i was like what
does that work she took me what she took
me
she's babysitting yeah i know i know
taking me to go see [ __ ] sinbad and
[ __ ]
and you were like so happy that she like
took you to scary movies because you
could like like all cling on her and
stephanie
yeah yeah yeah well she saved me yeah it
was her and her girlfriends
yeah it wasn't always just me and her it
was me and like two
or three of her other hot little hippie
girlfriends
they were all like you were like they're
little thirteen little babies
yeah the little baby i was a little baby
mascot
center of attention
[Laughter]
little hippie california girls [ __ ]
15 year old girls [ __ ] passing me
around in the movie theater
here you take him you know then they go
smoke pot and [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] funny
and laying on the bed laying on the
[ __ ] ground well it was
actually they didn't she'd have a bed
she just had a [ __ ] mattress on the
ground
she lit two two down doors be laying on
the [ __ ] ground and [ __ ] and they'd
have all the black lights on they were
smoking [ __ ] pot we're listening to
[ __ ] you didn't know led zeppelin
houses of the holy
[ __ ] they're just having fun you know i
wasn't smoking but they were smoking
well i was gonna say you're all a young
child abused you were getting you were
getting like some secondary smoke there
probably probably you were getting
like here over here and i'd be cuddling
[Laughter]
but that was just the way middle class
life was back in the 70s california
and we're taking the sequoia mountains
and we [ __ ] you know the [ __ ]
rangers are [ __ ] smoking weed and all
the [ __ ] teenage girls [ __ ]
nudes and [ __ ] run around just kind of
like in the 80s everyone was on youtube
yeah yeah they're playing [ __ ] heart
of glass
[ __ ] blondie heart of glass going on
the [ __ ] radio and [ __ ]
yeah it was it's just like it makes me
laugh because
i've seen it today i've seen pictures of
you as a kid so i know what you look
like
damien but it's much funnier to me
yeah to think of this story yeah but
like as you look now
but like really small yeah you know what
i mean
so like you look like you look now but
you're like this big
that's how i'm picturing it i had a 70s
haircut
okay thank you ken
i was wearing [ __ ] uh overalls stp
whole overalls and [ __ ]
yeah i've seen that red overalls yeah
like i was a mechanic
yeah it's like the kid the danny and the
shiny is a little girl
exactly he did yeah i think he did have
a little overalls
yeah i was older than him yeah yeah i
know what happened to that kid
he's around i know he's around what the
[ __ ] ever happened to i'm just saying
i just he's one of those kids that i
never really checked up on afterward
even though you think like everybody
would be he'd think he'd be doing
conventions
did he die yeah it's like um
what's the other the kid from
yeah what's this sixth sense then he he
grew up he's in some stuff but
oh he's a yeah he does a lot of
conventions i feel like he does yeah
but he's in like he kind of um became an
actor like as an adult
yeah i guess yeah um but
i don't know they seem to have like a
really hard time like trying some child
actors are
kind of stuck well it was all the damn
drugs
go to the restaurant yeah you kind of
just asking me if [ __ ] kimmy give me
a hand
no no that would be very inappropriate
you guys
it would be very well even for the 70s
that would be kind of yeah
we don't condone child sexual activity i
mean we did grow up in the 70s and
things were a lot different back then
but it wasn't that different
it's still not exciting it was still not
good no touching kids
don't do that stuff guys
yeah i don't know it's it's weird
because
i feel like like when we were talking
about before about like the trading
halloween candy and stuff
i feel like he didn't get because he's
an only child so i feel like he didn't
get a lot of the same experiences that i
had growing up because i have three
siblings so he's always kind of like we
were watching a movie the other day that
had like a brother and sister it wasn't
a great movie but it had like a brother
and sister
characters in it and he's sitting there
going like why it's like brothers and
sisters don't act like that i'm like how
the [ __ ] would you know
you don't have any sisters sisters i
know what sisters act like
i have two brothers and one sister so
you have the full experience so i have
the full experience i'm the oldest but
like
i have two brothers i have one brother
that's four years younger
i have a sister that's seven years
younger and i have another brother
that's
a lot younger he was born in
so i guess 14 years younger yeah
he's like the baby but yeah it's
i don't know it's it's just funny like i
knew some old
only children growing up it's kind of
like a different dynamic and it's just
weird to like talk about
with him sometimes because he it's weird
to me that he didn't have that
you know what i mean like growing up
that he didn't have like the sibling
experience well he doesn't need to
comment on movies that have siblings
then you're gonna be like no you don't
know
that's what i mean it's like you don't
really know like you don't have any
siblings so it's like
where are you coming from on this
although i'm always interested too
because a lot of people i know that have
siblings always talk about how oh me and
my siblings are so different and we
fought all the time
that's true and me and my siblings were
not like that even though there's like
big age gaps between us we're all like
very similar so it's like sometimes
like last time we got together maybe
like a year and a half ago
like my sister was here she lives in
atlanta and she came down to visit and
we all were like hanging at my brother's
house in daytona
and it's like we're almost all i i mean
i kid with my sister even though she's
seven years younger i'm like oh we share
a brain because like we should
we say like a lot of the same [ __ ] we
finish the other sentences and stuff
but even me and my brothers are like
really similar so it's like we all have
like really similar sense of humor we
all have like really similar tastes and
stuff
so it's like whenever we all get
together it's just kind of like this
really weird
like synergy because like all of us are
so alike
which i think that doesn't really happen
that much especially with like the huge
age gap in between us
but i don't know maybe maybe other
people have that [ __ ] too but
and it's weird too because my me and my
brother
lived with my like my parents divorced
when i was 14 and then my
me and my you know brother that's four
years younger we went and lived with my
dad
and then my sister and my youngest
brother went and lived with my mom so we
didn't even like
we kind of grew up with them but not
like after a certain time we grew up
like separately
but we're still like really really
similar so i think that's like really
funny because i don't think i've ever
i haven't really encountered much of
that like people that have siblings
that far apart that are that like
similar in personality but
now now i miss all my siblings i kind of
want to see them i haven't seen them in
such a long time
even though they don't live my sister
lives in atlanta but my brother lives
i have one brother that lives in ocala
and i have one brother that lives in
back in daytona where i grew up so i
don't know i need to go visit them maybe
but yeah so is he gonna like be in the
bathroom all day or what
he needs to get me another drink you're
just trying to finish this case aren't
you
i mean it's it's pretty much done i mean
like i said
the dude's body got passed around so
long that they didn't you know
i don't know what this guy was like in
real life but if it was my body and
that's just kind of how things rolled
it's kind of cool
you know like that's what i mean it is
kind of neat i don't think i would be
bothered
i like cheesy haunted houses and stuff
like that like i'm all about like really
campy horror [ __ ] so if my body got
bounced around by accident in a cheesy
campy horror
haunted house i think that'd be kind of
funny like yeah it's like if there was
an afterlife you'd kind of be like
smiling down
like someone did no one did it
maliciously like someone had come here
commenting about house of wax like yeah
it's kind of like that
but it wasn't done like on purpose it
just kind of happened
it just happened because like i said
yeah
so that's kind of funny you know first
thing you know like nobody claims your
body you get in bombs and bombers like
hey i need to make some money off this
[ __ ]
so i'm gonna like start selling it and
you know you go through a couple of
sales
and nobody's like look it's just a prop
for a haunted house so exactly
so it's mummified you don't know any
different yeah it's not the worst thing
i mean there's like dead bodies in
museums mommies and stuff
like it's not that much different you
just that's true
thank you jillian or gillian but it's
probably jillian i would think
did you ever see that um what was that
[ __ ]
uh they're saying i'm leaving and
farting on the cake no man
you better not be farting on my cake i
had to dab look these [ __ ]
are coming in i had to let pookie out
yeah
and pookie can't go out without a collar
so then i had to find the damn collar
there's and she knows the whole thing
she's like i want to go out and then you
go well hold on and i'm feeling i got
here it is and she goes yeah that's the
color and she sits there
yeah she's like do it do it and as soon
as she hears the click when the
when the collar snaps on because it's
got a it's got a quick release on it she
goes
okay and then she runs to the door and
it's a whole ritual
the whole ritual it's true she's
hilarious yeah she knows like i said she
knows the routine every single day
there's jillian alexis jillian alexis
was on here the other day
saying that she is she a gardener that
she's a garden gnome with a big ass and
some [ __ ] thighs and this and that
[ __ ] you're gonna have you're gonna
have to break it off
where are the pitchers you can't make
claims pictures you can't make claims
like that without trying to prove it
i can't say i'm a garden gnome with a
big old juicy ass
we were talking very early on we were
talking about sexy garden noses i'm like
wait minute is this
a sexy garden no what are you talking
about he's like we got to see this
go ahead and send your photos to jenny
she'll vet all that for us
that was what got me on that whole
discussion about yeah on our own like
sex halloween costumes you weren't here
jillian alexis miss jillian alexis
sexy garden gnome with a big old booty
card
why she'll get all kinds of private
messages and [ __ ] they're all gonna go
all these [ __ ] all these [ __ ] so
you really look like a dude
wait wait hold on do you look like a
sexy guardian can i have photographs
can i have one from the back
dudes are so weird yeah dudes are dudes
you have to understand it it's a visual
imagination is not enough but garden
gnomes though
yeah yeah yeah where is she i'm always
like where she says she is
it's jillian not with with a g jillian
with a g
yes okay okay so i said it right the
first time
it's usually jillian it's just like
sometimes i'm not really sure
because i don't know she says good lord
put me on blast dammit i'll send
jeanette
jenny whatever she wants coming at you
victor garcia says indeed there is no
porn on pornhub
yeah i figured probably jillian you
better be featured in some of that
there's porn for everything
there's porn for everything garden gnome
porn
i imagine i read an article a couple
years ago
about a woman who made a very good
living doing
porn where she would [ __ ] a
ventriloquist dummy
or she dressed like a ventriloquist
dummy and [ __ ] her intro
something like that i think there's lots
of those i don't remember what it was it
was something it was something like
more specific than that but i can't
really remember what it was but she made
a whole bunch of money
i'm like well it's a big world out there
and people have very
weird specifics see things that they
haven't seen i guess so
it's not necessarily like sexy to some
people but they're like yeah i want to
see that there's like some novelty
yeah just like the cake farting yeah the
captain is although i don't want to see
that
the captain is on there saying that the
sexy aspect of
of gnome porn garden gnome porn is the
cap
those caps and i don't know why why
because it's phallic
i don't know you calling him gay no i'm
just saying okay all right
no no i'm just wondering because it's
like long appointed okay i did not say
that
you're getting me in trouble yeah i'm
just getting you choked
it's all about the cat yeah i thought it
was all about the little gray beard
or the little sitting in the garden and
like watching you at all times
little garden gnomes now i want to guard
into him you want to guard no now
well you know just he could he could see
our housing commission will not allow us
to put gardens
are we not allowed to have garden over
there guaranteed did they specifically
they probably garden them
out there yeah we have two we have
h.o.a no garden gnomes allowed yeah
you can't even like park shitty looking
car i kind of feel like maybe my car is
too shitty looking to be here
your car is becoming borderline it is
it's probably like we're probably gonna
start getting like
this car warnings this car can't be
parked in this game
excuse me miss ashford we can't have
a white trash rattle trap like that out
of our
in our community our community yeah
that's what they call it
we did good on time it's all done huh
yeah i think so
like i said i had another case but i
took it out because it was too long and
involved and i didn't really want to get
into it yeah dj maniacs going wow he's
still going man
he's running errands and he comes back
and we're still long we're on
but uh we covered we covered most of it
we covered the topics what happened to
sophie i think she went to the bathroom
actually yeah she she'll be back in bed
you put you made you put pokey outside
pookie's outside
okay well that is the first time she
went out tonight so it was time yeah she
was kind of complaining she lets you go
out on the porch and
roll around in the dirt well if you got
you guys have any questions we can go
ahead and answer them now if not then
we'll be [ __ ] signing off here in a
minute because the show pretty much is
over
yeah because we got to kind of go i want
another piece of cake
we can get another piece of cake but we
got we have to guest on this other thing
coming up at 10 at 10 yeah so i might
have
cake and another drink before then so
i'll be really incoherent by the time
that that
comes around but like i said it's not
like it's a public
thing it's just like a [ __ ] all right
then let's go ahead and [ __ ]
shut it down do you want to shut it down
oh i want to say to you that like tammy
that sent me this card
yeah she put on the inside she says time
to
shut that [ __ ] down jenny because that's
what thomas says all the time
she wrote that on the inside of the card
which i thought look at all these pooky
cards that i have
so many pookie cards i have pookie cards
and a btk card
look at that [ __ ] all right so i guess
sophie's not because she's
she's not coming back and they're asking
us all kinds of [ __ ] about threesomes
she's just visiting she's just visiting
she has done reading she has a boyfriend
don't read anything
all right so uh that'll do it for this
episode
what the hell episode was this 2 15 yeah
uh urban legends
and other things oh now she's back i'm
sorry now that we're now that we're
ending
you're ending it that's okay we did good
normal time yeah three and a half that's
not yeah it's not too bad
three hours now he's in there trying to
pretend that he's bgk
we didn't have now we need to have
somebody like talk like h.h holmes
nobody knows what h nobody knows what he
sounds like because that was like a long
time ago something from
would it like some old-timey dude from
chicago sound like back then
he probably sounded nobody knows you
could make something up probably
i don't have a dude's voice so i
probably would have been something that
kind of sounded [ __ ] basically
transatlantic
yeah and now it's time for us to do
[ __ ] like that i didn't that's not what
i pictured i pictured something more
like
i don't know now i kind of got what he
got
people to come in his hotel and stuff
yeah that's true
kind of a hawkster all right so we're
gonna wrap this
up about urban legends and also probably
half about my birthday honestly
yeah but yeah okay oh somebody's victor
says he probably sounds like a dick
tracy gangster that's kind of
more what i thought of that i actually
thought of like an old-timey gangster
type of thing all right so we're gonna
wrap it up we will probably
live stream again tomorrow yeah and
probably soap will be with us next week
too so i'll be here well i'll be here i
leave next friday so i'll be here like
just through the week i tried to get her
to stay until [ __ ] monday
so she could do another big show but
she's awesome no
i've already got my you already got your
[ __ ] that's how they do it they want you
to book the whole thing
for just a few hours more we could have
got you in on an extra big show
well i don't know we won't find out what
the topic is until tomorrow when the
votes are
oh i gotta explode
there's one that seems like the one
topic that seems like it's a way to
check the other ones
so we'll see how that goes movies it's
always closer on the movies
but that one seems to be a clear
front-runner napkins now ken
is comparing me to [ __ ] jeffrey combs
and [ __ ] beyond him reanimated
i like i like i like jeffrey carlson
actually
if you ask me um jeffrey club's best
work was
uh star trek enterprise when he played
[ __ ] commander shrank commander
i [ __ ] um i have a
certain affinity for the commander
shrand character
that's [ __ ] what i would have been in
the star trek universe
god have been commander tran a man
working for a [ __ ]
a corrupt [ __ ] organization that was
telling her to do things that were
dishonorable i [ __ ] totally
understand it
he's like i feel you and he's come on
archer
you know you're [ __ ] pouring it
pouring the [ __ ] romulan ale you know
be a man archer stop being a [ __ ]
i can see you should dress up like tran
for halloween i need to get strand
outfit we need some halloween costumes
like for
because yeah i couldn't dress the shrimp
because one episode
our halloween episode is going to be on
actual halloween yeah
because it's on a saturday so we
probably need to like
rustle up some costumes we need to think
of something
well i mean you guys can just speak kirk
and spock like i think
that's true you just got to get the
shirt and you could just start your
eyebrows straight
you know yeah like and put some ears on
yeah some ears
like you could do it if you feel like a
female version
and then i could have an agonizer i
could like poke him with it the whole
time
or you could call him something else but
i mean it's easy to get shirt
and then that's true that would be
pretty like inexpensive
all right all right so uh that'll do it
for episode 215.
thank you everybody that stopped by
thank you everybody that contributed
gave me money for my birthday i really
had a good time
hanging out with you guys on my birthday
talking about some urban legends
uh but yeah you know like share
subscribe dude all do all that regular
[ __ ]
and uh remember go vote on the patreon
[ __ ] for
next week's topic and next week's movie
and uh tomorrow i'll tabulate all the
votes and i'll announce what
the next week's shows are going to be
and uh that'll do it so we will see you
tomorrow
bye